this is the municipal and county
committee
12 uh i rather 2 23 22
and we're gonna begin the day with the
pledge so would you please join me in
the pledge of allegiance
i pledge
and to the allegiance for which it
stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all thank you
please be seated
and as a reminder please turn your
microphone on when you speak and turn it
back off again
when you're not speaking
mr chairman yes
may i make a motion
yes
uh
upon reflection
i uh i determined that uh i voted
incorrectly on a house bill 1070.
may i ask the uh
uh
the committee to reconsider the bill
yes
that's that's uh
a motion if you want to make that motion
well
i asked for a reconsider on house bill
1070. you want to make a motion to
reconsider
yes and you want to
second it
okay uh we're looking at now at uh a
bill we we uh
exec yesterday
it's uh house bill 1070
and the motion on the floor is to
reconsider
is there any discussion on that motion
seeing oh yes representative gallagher
um so could we get a reminder of which
bill that was
1070. well like i mean
what was it about though
this is the the default budget uh
bill we had yesterday on official
official ballot jurisdictions
any other questions on the bill yes
representative wrong
thank you mr chairman i just want to
remind the committee that uh testimony
we had from the new hampshire municipal
association and the municipal uh bureau
for the department of revenue
administration
um both said that this bill
creates multiple technical difficulties
with current statute
i just don't think it's the responsible
thing for this committee to recommend a
bill pass that
um if it goes into law creates
difficulties with the law it creates
inconsistencies i i think that's a very
irresponsible thing to do
we
voted down the amendment but even the
amendment
only addresses one of those issues
i just don't think it's good practice
for legislators to pass
illegal
bills thank you thank you
uh i just want to reiterate uh mr thank
you i just want to reiterate that the
amendment um
is contrary to uh the amendment at line
nine
is contrary to line 18 making a big
circle that towns are going to have to
struggle with whether they take
something out or
use the contracts as previously approved
whether you've made a reduction or not
um i i i think administrators and
and governing bodies are going to be
scratching their heads over this one
any further discussion yes represent yes
excuse me representative majority
thank you mr chair it's just a question
i i want to confirm that the
disposition of that bill was ten to
eight in favor of itl and our
reconsideration is of that vote is that
correct
uh what was the vote yes yes okay thank
you
seeing no further discussion
oh
reconsider you want to uh no i just have
a question about the motion to
reconsider
um does that have to be made by someone
who was on the prevailing side no that's
only on the on the house floor oh okay
thank you
i was on the prevailing side by the way
that's of no consequence it's that limit
doesn't doesn't affect us in command
but it's a good thought though because
we do if you are thinking of
reconsideration on the house floor for
any bill you have to be in the
you have to be in the uh
the minority decision
to reconsider
okay uh seeing no further discussion uh
we'll ask
the clerk to take the role on
reconsideration of 1070.
okay hb 1070 reconsideration uh
vice chairman pmrt yes
clerk votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas yes
representative platt
yes
representative melvin
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majorie
no
uh representative tray 11 no
representative gilman no
representative davis no
representative megapootie
no
representative
representative clee no
representative gallagher
no
representative ron no
and chairman dolan yeah
uh motion passes ten tonight okay so at
this point uh i'm going to look to
representative tripp
since the
we just voted on the motion to
reconsider
now now we need to disposition the bill
i move uh otp on house bill 1070
point of order is that is there a second
for that
i'll second it mr chairman okay
my understanding is that a vote to
reconsider just goes back to the
previous motion so my understanding is
we have to vote on the itl
if that fails then we bring otp motion
forward
okay uh representative trip with you
withdraw your motion i would draw my
motion
representative lasallis
yes mr chairman okay
so
now we need representative trip
motion
so we're back to the itl is that right
you're all
good with that
all right so
the uh motion
is to itl
hb 1070. uh i like to take a roll mr uh
uh
guthrie
what's that trip uh representative
triple silas on the no
they're back to the original motion okay
chip and guthrie yeah okay
from yesterday yeah
i don't believe i
made a motion to itl i think uh oh i'm
sorry
i think i might have made that notion
yeah
yes got it
okay so there is a motion on the floor
mr clerk would you call the roll
okay 1070 ital uh
vice chairman pm monty
no
collect votes no
representative tripp no
representative guthrie
representative losalas no
representative polite
no
representative melvin
representative here
no
representative power
represent majority yes
representative trail evan yes
representative gilman yes
representative stavis yes
representative meg caputi
yes
representative
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan yes
and shimon dolan
no
given the fact that uh
itl has failed
uh we i need to look to house bill 1070
for another motion
i move otp on house bill 1070. okay is
there a second i'll second it
mr chair yes is it disgusting otp
a because it's there's an amendment to
10.70
all right
okay uh
please call the roll
questions
you have a question
are we are we deci are we going to
debate the otp motion
i called for discussion it wasn't
anything oh i'm sorry but i'll if
there's still some simmering out there
i'll let it come out
thank you mr chair i just want to point
out that the uh
sign in sheets for positions on this
bill were
13 in support but 29 opposed okay thank
you for that and
somebody else have uh
something they wanted to add to the
discussion
thank you mr chair and this is just a
general observation that pertains to
this bill nonetheless
which is that this committee is
generally in favor of passing enabling
legislation
and tends to shy away from statewide
bans or permissions or anything that
forces towns and cities
to give up
local control and i would just note that
this is not enabling legislation this is
a mandate
uh and it would
would affect all towns no matter what
their character no matter what their
process
and it just seems contrary to what we
typically do here
thank you for that reminder
seeing no further discussion i asked the
clerk to call the role
1070 otp
uh vice chairman pmit yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
yes
representative los alas yes
our representative plate
yes
representative melvin
yes representative here
yes
representative power
majority no
representative
no
representative gilman no
representative davis no
representative megapootie no
representative vann
no
representative clee
representative gallagher
no
representative ryan no
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 10 tonight
thank you mr clerk uh the next uh bill
in our mr chair yes just want to note
that there will be a minority report on
this i think we have representative vann
who will be writing the minority report
although it could be representative
gilman
do you defer
representative gilman are you good
writing the minority report for this
thank you
okay and the
majority report will be written
by representative tripp
thank you
okay the next line of business is
house bill 1081.
it's when we skipped over yesterday
we're going to take it up today
1081 is the bill
it's relative to the dissolution of a
village district
yes yeah
mr chairman i'd like to move itl on
house bill 1081.
is there a second
may i speak to my motion thank you um
i'm from merrimack and we have a village
district that provides municipal water
to most of our towns
and although a village district can be
established through a majority of the
voters
in the legislative body
i believe dissolution should remain at
two-thirds
the reason is and i'm speaking from
miramax experience is we have tens of
millions of dollars of infrastructure
and i think a decision to dissolve
that much capital
that's owned by the village district
should require at least the same
deliberation and threshold
that a bond does and a bond requires
two-thirds so um i just think this is a
decision that that requires
a much more support than what we see for
decisions that don't involve this level
of
investment in money thank you
okay
thank you uh and
just to make sure i'm not being rude uh
let me introduce representative pled
who is filling in today as a substitute
and thank you for being here
i i appreciate the opportunity
okay we're back to uh house bill 1081.
we've had some discussion is there any
further discussion before we
take a vote
the uh the motion on the floor is the
itl
say no further discussion ask the clerk
to call the vote
okay itl 1081
uh vice chairman piamonti no
clerk votes no
representative tripp
i vote no
representative guthrie
representative losales
no
representative platt
representative melvin
no
representative
representative power
no
representative mijori
yes
representative tray 11 yes
representative gilman yes representative
stavis yes
representative mega poody
yes
representative vann
representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
yes representative wrong
yes and chairman dolan
no
vote is uh ten a's and nine yays motion
fails
thank you mr clerk uh
to write the uh committee report
representative trump
so so now uh representative triple
looking for a motion
uh mr chair i move uh otp on house bill
1081.
thank you is there a second for that
okay representative
representative did you have something
you wanted
yes representative wrong
yeah i just uh
um i'm opposed to the ought to pass for
the same reasons i was in support of the
itl
many village districts in this state
have millions and millions of dollars of
capital
and
assets
those should be treated as respectfully
as we treat bond issues which can even
be substantially lower amounts of money
i believe it's fiscally irresponsible
to treat dissolutions of village
districts with less attention and
responsibility than we do bond issues
thank you
any further discussion no representative
majority
thank you mr chair i agree uh with my
friend from merrimack completely
northampton has a village district which
has been in existence for over 100 years
it has their own
building department their own zoning
their own cip their own heritage
commission
their own budget committee their own
board of commissioners they make their
own rules
to assume that all of the infrastructure
and everything else that has been
incorporated into that town by their
vote
could be undone by a majority vote i
think is completely irresponsible it
should require a two-thirds vote and i
will be voting against the otp thank you
any further discussion
yes
thank you mr chair i would like to point
out again that the opposition to this
bill uh as submitted was 21 with only
four in support thank you
thank you for keeping track of those
numbers
uh see no further discussion
oh
representative
thank you mr chair i'm hiding over here
i'd like to comment on the fact that
we're talking about two different things
here we're talking about an amorphous
idea
constructed by people
the village district and then we are
talking about
specific hard infrastructure
owned by that amorphous idea
meaning
water sewer electricity whatever sorts
of
um
girding is supporting that village
district and i need i think we need to
be very
clear that we're not just dealing with
an amorphous idea we're dealing with
concrete tangible
items that have an economic impact
on the people who live in that amorphous
village district thank you
amorphous
are you looking it up yes
it's kind of a
uh it can mean solid examples it also
can mean something that's sort of
fungible evolving
amorphous it's an id it's a it's a
construct it's an idea i appreciate that
sorry when you stretch
my brain a little bit i like that thank
you thank you for your assistance
is there further discussion
so without any further discussion
we are ready to take a vote
on
house bill 10
70.
i'm sorry 1081 i'm going backwards here
1081.
um
representative tripp do you have a
motion
oh you already made the motion not to
pass
okay so so we had the motion and we've
uh
did we get a second
lasalle seconded it no no representation
air seconded it all right
so now it's time to take a vote
mr clerk
thank you mr chairman otp on 1081
vice chairman p monty
yes
clerk for ots
representative tripp yes
representative guthrie
representative silas
yes
representative platt
yes representative melvin yes
representative here
yes
representative power yes
probably the majority no
representative evan no
representative gilman no
representative stavis no
representative mega pooty
no
representative
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
representative run no
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes
uh 10 to 9.
that concludes the
executive
discussion on
1081.
all right we're going to move on to uh
to exec house bill 1122
which is authorizing municipalities to
collect and resell construction debris
and
i'm looking to representative power for
a motion
mr chair i'd like to make a motion ought
to pass on house bill 1122
second
has been made
representative
we have an amendment on this
no no amendment okay
yes representative
thank you mr chair um
i had sent over communication that i had
with the prime sponsor about this
um that karen representative ebel
who is working diligently on rules for
recycling and composting and ascending
stuff or is working through gel car in
the process
that may
improve this bill and another bill that
we have coming up in another exec 1406 i
sent information over about that
which would
mean that it might be better to interim
study this bill rather than to pass it
now because if we pass it now we may
need to make considerable changes to it
after those rules have been adopted
i have no problem with letting the vote
go through as it is
but i just wanted to say that that was
the conversation with the prime sponsor
that he would support interim study for
uh for this bill
representative melvin did you have a
comment
no
are there any other comments
yes representative
representative maturity and your
discussion what were some of the items
that he was talking about
i'm sorry uh uh what were some of the
items in your discussion that they were
talking about
it was thank you
thank you it was uh they weren't talking
about anything specific
uh in there that's what we were waiting
to see what were the specific rules that
we were going to be seeing so it was
just uh it was representative ebel who
had reached out to the prime sponsor uh
with that request and said you may want
to pump the brakes it's it's you know
you don't have to but you may want to
pump the brakes on this
rather than have to revisit something in
the future
i'm sorry that i don't have that answer
for you sorry
yes go ahead please
um thank you mr chair um in uh further
discussion about this
i've been talking to the
chair that is uh
representative ebel about solid waste
management especially municipal waste
management and they are working on that
that commission is working diligently on
trying to address which is a big issue
uh in our state
and
absolutely representative maggiore
alluded to what's happening so this all
in a big discussion
to bring in something and then try to
amend it or change it would be a lot
more
cumbersome
so interim study would give that
opportunity to
flush it out and bring a good bill back
thank you
wait a minute we're gonna go to
representative
clay first
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr vice chair uh for letting me speak um
i i would have no problem if it got
changed to interim study um i do like
the idea of this and i have spoken to
our um
waste collection uh people
we're in the city of nashville we're
very unique in that we don't allow
dumping other than we have no contracts
or anything like that so it's basically
got to be residential dumping in our
particular thing but we are as everybody
else going to be losing space and one of
the things when i brought this up they
were quite interested because we're
considering doing our um construction
jumping changing it from
a
ton
to 300 a ton um just for that particular
reason so to be able to do something
like this i think would be a good idea
but i would like it to go through as
clean as possible so
if it's recommended if it's changed to
recommend to interim study that would be
a good idea
but i am for this this type of
legislation as well thank you
just so you know
i've asked the vice chair to contact the
clerk
to
inquire about the
hierarchy emotions does the interim
study
uh is that a higher motion than we have
on the floor
so if that if that's the case excuse me
yeah we have emotion
so uh if that comes back that it's a
higher motion then we'll we'll jump to
that motion
but uh i'm willing to have continued
discussion if you want to representative
gallagher
um well just
um all right so
i guess he's not here to hear it anymore
but for um
any of the rest of you were sharing rep
pia monty's
question about what exact sort of
changes would be made in an interim
study committee one thing i had for my
notes was
the case that representative stavis
brought up of the trains
um bringing
debris to claremont to come
dump there so
yeah i think
an interim study could
help us
find language to
handle that case
specifically so that
it meets the approval of
people involved
so that that's one
reason i see interim study that's a good
idea
okay represents davis
thank you mr chair
just to to
put a little more flesh on the bones of
the claremont issue which i raised in
the hearing
a private freight company wanted to
establish an outpost in the city of
claremont
where they would deliver and process
hundreds of thousands of pounds of
construction debris on a daily basis
with trains going in and out of the city
24 7.
the people of clermont
raised
of objections to this and it didn't pass
and the
point that i was trying to make in the
committee hearing
was that we have no we the state have no
power over what the railroads do they
are under federal jurisdiction
but passing a law such as this
might give them a very convenient leg up
in the process
and why as a state would we do that why
would we seed that kind of control to
the federal government when we don't
currently do it and we don't need to do
it
and many municipalities already
receive and process and sell
construction debris thank you
thank you
uh representative mcguire
next uh representative powell oh i'm
sorry i i didn't notice the right right
thank you uh representative pimanti i'm
just looking through the emails i have
from representative ebel
it's a it's a very short thing and it
said this this came in last week
des is two to three weeks away from
sending new compost regulations to gel
car
so a process is underway to simplify
composting for towns and other entities
this is what we might want to
incorporate into
both 1122 and 1406 should you consider
interim study
so again not not as specific as we might
want but knowing something is coming
thank you representative power
i just had an inquiry my notes say that
it was suggested that representatives
egan
stavis and manjapudi
work with
new hampshire municipal association
to um
bring forward an amendment
did
did that happen or not
is there amendment on the floor
no amendment yeah um in response to that
we did get a email i did get an email
from the sponsor
but again because of representative
ebel's email who's working on a
statewide commission
you know that was
we didn't move further on my
participation would have been handling
the
municipal solid waste
aggregation of all of the waste and
that was one piece of the puzzle
but because we got this email the prime
sponsor
and uh the municipal association when we
had that email conversation that was uh
deemed uh
best to do an interim study and push
this off rather than pushing something
through uh for the sake of pushing it
through
representatives
yeah thank you mr chair and just for
further clarification for those on the
committee who may not have been here in
the last session or who are subbing
this committee has taken on the issue of
solid waste
in the past
and we have taken a very careful look at
it and we consulted with public works
whose chair was karen ebel at the time
who then created this task force
and i believe that the amendment that
representative power may be referring to
was a conversation
with representative ebel to determine
where the task force stood in its
disposition on issues of solid waste
relating to the state and not an
amendment
that may just have been a difference in
understanding of the communication
however this committee has worked
diligently
with
the public works committee on the issue
of solid waste and the waste stream in
general in the state
and
comprehensive legislation to address
that growing problem
is in the works and
small pieces of legislation like this
one and uh could
result in
kind of contra indications to what that
commission ultimately
recommends and therefore this will have
to be repealed or amended or and it
would be cumbersome
so it would be prudent in my view to
wait and see what that commission
recommends and what des recommends as a
result
and then
take another bite at these bills
thank you thank you uh we we have had
some more discussion but i want to ask a
question representative davis is it your
understanding that
that if this bill were to pass that
claremont
would no longer have control
over this that that even if they didn't
want this debris in their town they're
going to get in any way because of the
railroad connection
thank you mr chair it's a really good
question
um
no
i think what i was trying to express was
that railroads have tremendous federal
power and protection and every piece of
legislation that we pass at the state
level
that
eases the way of a railroad that goes
through a community that may not want
hazardous waste going through its
community just makes it easier
for them to do that
and therefore i think it's not prudent
of us to give them a leg up
they already have a leg up why give them
another one
thank you representative tripp
thank you mr chair uh
in my notes i i uh
i see a
an uh an item that says that this is an
enabling bill
which means that uh not this is not
something that's a state mandate that uh
the uh
towns and cities and
whatever uh
allow
uh dumping of construction and
demolition waste at their uh transfer
stations
um
i i
i tend to agree with you that uh
if if a town
isn't planning on doing this then some
guidance would be helpful as to setting
the rules of how the uh the
dumping of uh construction and
demolition
uh debris
uh is going to work but if the town is
interested in doing something i i'm
assuming that
they have looked into
what types of
construction and demolition debris is
going to be accepted and how it's going
to be processed
and
what uh benefits would result from this
so i am in favor of this bill and i will
vote be voting yes
uh representative uh
thank you mr chair and thanks everyone
for your comments i'm gonna bring us
back to the to the trash yard where this
debris is going and
talk for a moment about the fact that
in my town dover there are some
materials we don't take
but in the town next to us which is
rochester new hampshire they take
lots of stuff and both of these entities
our transfer stations in rochester's
would love to be able to resell any
construction debris that was resellable
they need help and guidance as to what
that is
why make each town
reinvent the wheel
each time they may want to do it
when we can take a step back
and give some guidance to our local
communities regarding
what is left over woodwork what is
leftover this and that work what is not
worth anything and needs to be
thrown away because the bill talks about
collecting and reselling and i think
that's what lights everybody's eyes up
because we all like
more profit for our communities
and more ecologically friendly practices
going forward
so i think that an interim study
resolution to this bill would be great
because there are mines working together
to put out a better solution
that everyone could choose from still an
enabling possibility but not everybody
having to reinvent that solution going
forward thank you
thank you mr chair
to
elaborate a little more on my colleague
just know who spoke to
say
this is the step in the right direction
but
there's a major effort
statewide a commission that was
established
to study exclusively the municipal
solid waste and disposal
and all the issues surrounding waste
management
is happening
and why
not wait of you know just a little bit
in a few weeks
some
statewide guidelines is going to come up
if they're already putting all the time
and effort
and just wait isn't this what we do as a
legislators to
understand the study and understand the
issue and make the right decision which
is enabling for the local community so i
think with that in mind
i'm just saying you know we have
going in the right direction but put it
as an interim study and incorporate what
happens
in a few weeks
thank you
yes thank you mr chairman i have a a
question
uh
in my town we don't allow
any uh
uh construction material in our uh uh of
our site but my question is and i don't
know if anybody can answer it is
can't the towns do this now what do we
need a bill to allow
something that the town can do as a
local option anyway again
so i i'm sort of at a loss
there is
in the in the
as i look at the
the
wording of the bill this is this says
that the town may do this
and that implies that they may not do it
if
if they
this is if the bill passes so if they
choose hey what we don't want anything
this construction debris in our town
they could say no
it feels like enabling but yeah i
understand that mr chairman but my
question is can't the local communities
do this
now without this bill
and i ask if there's any member of the
committee that might have that
information
thank you mr chair thank you
representative guthrie i think it's a
great question
and um specifically my understanding is
that a town cannot resell construction
debris at this point
the
site the landfill in rochester new
hampshire is owned by
waste management company they're a
private company they provide a service
to the public
to my town as well they collect our
rubbish these days we have a contract
with them
they can resell construction debris
but
but a town
municipality on its own cannot as far as
i understand the only reason waste
management can do it is because they're
a private company they still have issues
with
sorting that debris
what goes where what can they do and
it becomes kind of trashy
thank you very much for that information
representative thank you mr chairman
thank you representative
uh yes i in in
sandown we have a
tank we have a
site
i'm sorry
okay sorry about that
um in sandown we have a a tank that we
put construction debris in
um
and then we have also another area where
we put like brick or
rock or things of that nature
and they use that pretty much as a
landfill type of thing
i'm just wondering did
i don't know what they did they burn
this uh say the wood from the
construction debris or i know that the
pressure treated wood goes in a separate
area that they can't burn
but um i'm just wondering
what value is of this debris we're
talking about
yes representative i think that's the
goal of the interim study representative
piemonte to find out
what the value is and how to do it i'm
sure there are other
states in the united states of america
that do this and we could learn from
their experience
okay just have a follow-up follow-up uh
yes the um
i know when the hauler hauls it away and
it goes by a certain dollar amount per
ton
um i i would like to see on that if it
goes to an interim study to uh
take those things into consideration
because uh
um i mean
it might be cheaper just to leave it the
way it is
representative
oh now representative gilman
thank you mr chair one of the other
things that came up during the testimony
was um
whether or not we might want to make a
regional
construction debris area
which is something that would be
considered an interim study
because it certainly hasn't been talked
about here
thank you uh any further discussion
yes
representative
in in my town what we do is we we have
containers for up for uh construction
material and we take it in from three
other towns
we get paid
coming in the door but we pay it going
out the door
is that is that a profitable
situation yes
we'd like to get paid going out the door
too representative clay
uh thank you mr chairman i think one of
the if i remember correctly in the
conversation is that
when
people um
do their the dumping of this material
they do have to pay x amount per ton as
as was spoken here
and whether it's sorted or not it does
go up but this gives the opportunity of
the
people who are doing the demolition
to not have to pay that tipping fee or
whatever cost you want to call that
because it could be resold
um and it was kind of a win-win
situation or they would pay less
on a tipping fee so i think it was a win
that it didn't just become
it could get reused by habitat and i
think some of the materials may have
been um construction materials of
of wood but also of like cabinetry doors
i think were mentioned and so on so i
think and because it's enabling i i
think that's what um
one of the benefits of it were that we
could work with people in construction
it didn't fill up our landfills it kind
of went back out there as i said like
something for a habitat for humanity or
someone who was looking for doors or of
some that nature if i remember correctly
thank you i'm going to end the dialogue
on this particular bill right now and
we're going to recess this bill and take
it up after lunch
yes
you need a comment
is is that something we can do or
i wasn't there something i can do wasn't
there emotion on it
uh no it doesn't need an emotion
okay
at this point i want to take up
house bill 1136
which requires planning boards to list
the type of studies required to render a
decision
representative
ayer you have a motion
is it seconded
i'd like to second that mr chair okay
thank you is there a discussion on this
bill
the motion is to itl
seeing no further discussion we'll ask
the
clerk to call a roll
itl on 1136 uh vice chairman p monty yes
black votes yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yes
representative salas
yes
uh representative platt yes
representative melvin yes representative
here yeah representative power yes
represent majority yes
representative trail oven yes
representative gilman yes
representative davis yes
representative megaputi yes
representative vann yes
representative klee yes representative
gallagher
yes
representative yes
and chairman dolan yes
19-0 the itl passes hey without
objection i'll put that on the consent
calendar
okay the next uh item on our agenda is
house bill 1155
which is relative to persons elected to
a local board
serving on another board
i
like to look to representative trip for
a motion
mr chair i uh move interim study for
house bill 11 55 is there a second
i will second that mr chairman may i
speak to my motion
yes uh
this is an interesting bill
uh there are
people that believe that uh
the governing body has uh
their fingers into other
uh entities within the uh
municipal
uh
organization and that they should be uh
uh limited
there are other
people that believe that uh this is uh
a good idea
i mean a bad idea and that uh you know
uh
appointed boards
uh appointing a uh ex official member
they should have the same rights as uh
the
the appointed members so uh
i i believe that
there's such a uh
a broad range of
uh
how this is handled within a state right
now
that uh
an interim study would
would make
a any attempt to
legislate a change
much much more
clear
that's why i
support this bill the
motion
thank you representative power
thank you mr chair um
i'm not sure if this is appropriate at
this time but there is an amendment to
this bill
is
can i pass that out or i'm not clear
about the procedure
uh just as a heads up thinking about
this i'll i will before we dispose of
this bill i'll be asking for
volunteers to work on the interim study
if that motion passes
representative
oh you're you're volunteering
not quite there yet
representative power
would you like me to speak to this
amendment
yes uh
because we took the motion
to um
yeah we have a motion on the floor right
now to uh
to uh vote for interim study um
it's slightly unusual that
that we have a discussion on it but
in order to be
as open and
accommodating as possible i'll
accept your discussion on the amendment
thank you mr chair i have a follow-up so
just
for me to understand as a freshman
due to the fact that we have a motion on
the floor for i interim study that does
not pertain to an amendment therefore
it's not appropriate for me to speak to
the amendment because we're not voting
on that so if that's the case i
would not like to speak to the amendment
because it's inappropriate
any further inputs on
on that
all right let's dispose of the amendment
and if it if
if the bill is still alive then we'll
come back to the amendment
so the motion on the floor is the
interim study
hp 11
55.
is there any further discussion on
interim study
seeing none uh i'll ask the clerk to
take the role
okay 11 55 and gym study uh
vice chairman pmonty yes
collect votes yes representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative silas
yes
uh representative platt yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative mijori
yes
representative tray 11 yes
representative gilman yes
representative davis yes
representative megaputi
yes
representative van
okay
uh representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
representative rung yes
and shannon dolan
no
uh 17-1
we're destined to have an interim study
on
11 55
and we do we have any volunteers who
work on that i don't know
see melvin
i'd like to have at least one democrat
no paul's not a democrat no i
interim study on
uh 11 55
either i need you either to accept the
assignment or appoint somebody i serve
at the pleasure of the chair just tell
me where to go when to be there
thank you
your brother
maggiore is also part of the interim
study
if you're a pia monkey
piante melvin and jori
and i i might encourage the uh those
appointed to that
interim study that you consider uh
the amendment that i didn't get to
which is uh
zero seven seven three h
as part of your
study
mr chair yes just a question on the
interim study the first named um we'll
we'll send out will the first name
be the one sending out uh the
information about scheduling and such
no uh representative pierre monte will
do that and he will he is assigned as a
chair okay of the study
and it will be his responsibility to
report back
thank you
okay
next we have
hp 1161 fn local relative the ethics
obligations of elected
local and county officials
representative tripp do you have a
motion you like to make
i would like to move uh itl house bill
i'd like to second that
is that
power
oh there you are
when it comes to the speaker system i
don't get the direction of where it came
from
may i speak to my motion yes
you may uh
my primary uh contention with this
is it's it's essentially a
a recall bill
and
this is not the way things are done in
new hampshire you know
uh
people serve
their term
and the voters determine
you know
whether they're suitable for their
office
and for another term and i'm going to
support my itl
okay representative gallagher
so
um i'd just like to say that
um so yeah i agree with the motion to
itl
and i want to clarify that in
supporting itl in this it's not about
the general idea of having ethics
standards or anything that's about
this build just being
it doesn't seem well thought out enough
the
uh sponsor seemed unable to answer a lot
of the questions
we had for
him about it and
it seems like it really could have used
a lot more work so
um
yeah i i think that is why it makes
sense to go to idea on this
thank you representative gallagher uh
representatives davis
thank you mr chair
um i also support the itl motion
uh
for
all of the reasons representative tripp
enumerated but in addition i support the
itl motion because of the bill stating
that the person who found quote unquote
guilty of such an ethics violation will
be
charged with a misdemeanor
which is a heavy thing
in this state and really needs to be
thought out by the criminal justice
committee and there needs to be a a
process
due process given to anyone who's
charged of a crime in this state and
that bill that bill does not do this
if i could add to that i think that
part of the
the issue here is that if someone is
charged with a misdemeanor on a public
board in most towns
i can't say oh most towns that
that means they must leave the board
that they're appointed to
so the punishment is
more severe than we might be thinking
representative maturity do you have a
comment
thank you mr chair i support the itl
motion and go back to the uh to the
document that northampton adopted and
encourage anybody to just um google
ethics northampton and you'll see the
case that we had there
that was the first test of our ethics
ordinance that was passed by the voters
of northampton the legal fees cost more
than 20 thousand dollars during the
first test
of that document which has already been
vetted by council
and under that first test and under all
those legal fees again to reiterate what
i said in the public hearing it was
proven that that document was
poorly written and could not be executed
could not be adjudicated i love the
intent
but the execution is extraordinarily
difficult and will be tested in court so
thank you representative
thank you mr chair in my notes i support
the itl for a couple of reasons one is
uh to add to all the previous speakers i
also asked the question of the prime
sponsor at that time
so
was the intention of this bill to
enhance
individual moral and ethical value
system by enforcing collective effort or
legislating
the individual moral and ethical values
and
he did indicate yes and that would be a
tall order to
be able to enforce
in the enhanced individual moral and
ethical values through legislatively
collective effort
and
with that you know this is a
you know holding elected official
to a higher standard yes i agree we need
to have that but not with the
criminal charge
or the criminal hammer hanging over the
head to say if you violate the ethical
or moral value system then you are
penalized criminalized for that so for
that
i think this is
not a bill that we can
i would support itl
i will support itl at this time thank
you any other discussion
seeing then let me let me mention that
my experience with this in my community
is that we do have in londonderry we do
have an ethics
ordinance
i'm not a big fan of it i don't think
you can legislate
good behavior or moral conduct
and it is my
thought that ethics rules ought to be
much more aspirational
than
mandates
so um
but we we have it and
we've had it now for
i think
14 years
and
so far nobody
has been brought up on an ethics
violation
in 14 years
i don't think that's a
testament to the
good behavior of the community i think
it's a testament to the fact that
it's very hard to enforce these types of
vague
issues like i said i it's my thought
that this should be much more
aspirational than than
directed
additional comments from the committee
okay
[Music]
we have a motion on the floor to itl
uh hb 1161 you want to call the roll
yes mr chairman itl 1161. vice chairman
pia monty yes clerk votes yes
representative tripp
hi vote yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative losis yes
representative platt yes
representative melvin yes
representative here
representative power yes
majority yes
representative trey levin yes
representative gilman yes
repressed davis yes
representative mangapudi
yes representative
yes representative clee
yes representative gallagher
yes
representative rung yes
and chairman dolan
yes
19-0
without objection i'll place this on the
consent calendar
mr chair yeah this has a fn can you do
that
that's a good question uh i may not be
able to i'll but it is local
it doesn't say
it's an fn local so
so but i'll double check if i can't put
it on the calendar it'll be in the
regular calendar
representative did you have some wisdom
it just got cleared up thank you
okay
next we have a bill about composting
hp 1172 fn which is
requires a composting and waste
recycling to be made available to
residents of public housing
representative lasallis do you have a
motion
yes mr chairman although the intent of
this bill is very
admirable
during our discussion of the bill it
seemed to me as if
the
implementation of this
would be very cumbersome at this point
down the road
we may be able to do that but
i will move itl
thank you
for that mr chair
mr chair i have a question for the chair
the prime sponsor has his hand up and he
might have an amendment so wouldn't that
be something that we would consider
just a question to the chair thank you
we have do we have an amendment on
the prime sponsor is holding it up and
having
has his hand up so
all right uh representative lasalles
would you withdraw your motion i will mr
chairman
in deference to the prime sponsor okay
so do we have any further discussion
before we get to this prime sponsor
uh representative gallagher would like
to speak to this
so yes i have an amendment to
introduce to
this bill based on
our
discussion in the hearing about it
so
it
makes reference to
it adds a reference to rsa 149
m colon 2 which was something that
representative gilman
suggested
it gives a definition for public housing
because that was
a question about what exactly this law
would apply to
the definition here we're using it
administered by a public housing
authority
that adds the word
onsite
to clarify
where
where exactly this compost and recycling
has to be
and it changes
facility to receptacles or bins since
there were some questions about what
exactly was meant by
a facility
so um
i i hope that helps
clarify
some of the questions people had about
the
implemented implementation details
of
this legislation
thank you uh yes representative
vann
i move we adopt the amendment as
proposed
second
yes
we don't have copies of the amendment is
it coming or
oh is it
oh this is it i'm sorry yeah um i i
believe i handed it around um there's
more over there on the table if
it hasn't my mistake i did find it yes
okay so we have a motion and a second on
the amendment
yes representative
uh
may i speak to the the amendment yes
you've made
one of the issues that uh
was uh brought up in the uh
the hearing
of the uh the bill was that uh
well there
it does talk to
uh the collection
of uh the compost scene material
it really doesn't talk to what's going
to be done with it once it's collected
and uh i see that
the amendment
doesn't uh
uh answer that question either
so uh
it's it's a laudable uh thing to do
because
composting would would uh
reduce the uh the loading of the uh
trash in the uh
landfills but uh like i said this this
still doesn't answer the question of
what do you do with the the compost once
you've collected it thank you
thank you is there further discussion is
representative wrong
yeah i share representative tripp's
concern um but i'm going to support the
amendment and hope that it serves to
um
provide information for perhaps interim
study
further discussion yes
yes of course i'm a sub in the committee
it wasn't part of the hearings when it
took place but my question in my mind is
is there room everywhere to put another
bin
besides recycle and solid waste is is is
there a constraint at least some public
housing which would make it very
difficult to do
thank you mr chair um
i'm going to echo what i hear from my
friend representative wrong
that um i can support the amendment
because i think it improves the bill
but i i might want to uh hope that this
bill will go to interim study under the
same conditions that 11 22
and later 1406
i'm going to hope for the same thing
because we might get information from
des
that that improves the situation uh for
for these folks and and answer some of
the questions that we are raising here
thank you yes you have a question
representative
yes
in public housing do you have to get
permission
from it oh sorry
yeah thank you very much
uh in public housing do you have to get
permission from the housing authority to
implement this
um well the housing authority
the housing authority runs the building
like if someone were
just to put out one
of their own recycling bins or
um
or
compost bins there's no real guarantee
as to what would happen to it um
like
you know they they they have
they the public housing authority owns
the property and have the right to do
with it as they please
so
my point
um
it didn't quite answer my question
were they notified in
agreement with this or
um
how how does that work i mean i
understand if somebody puts out a bin
and they don't
you know
they have to approve it i would assume
um
so my question is has they approved this
so yes i did try um reaching out to
my local housing authority
about
this bill
and
wasn't really able to get a clear answer
out of them as to
where exactly they stood on it so
that's why
that's why i think
if we do legislation we'll get certainty
quicker rather than if we just wait
around for the public housing authority
to
make up its mind i didn't hear that last
statement i'm sorry all right follow up
could you repeat that last sentence you
said i didn't i couldn't hear it with
the
face um
so i i think that um
i i think that
if
we pass this bill legislatively that
will be a quicker way to get
certainty about
this situation than
it would be
if
i were just to continue to wait around
to hear back and answer from
the public housing authority on my own
thank you
yes representative
um
i'm not aware of any instance in which
legislation that we are considering must
be approved by unauthority that it
might be subject to
i i don't
understand how that question is germane
to either via the amendment or the bill
but having said that
um
should def
issue new recommendations which they
surely will be doing along with the
solid waste commission
it would be um
a violation of the rights of residents
of public housing where the
hud not to provide the same benefits
that other citizens enjoy
but but having said that i'm not aware
that we ask permission or approval from
any organization that our legislation
addresses
when we are considering such legislation
further discussion
yes
representative gilman
thank you mr chair uh one thing i'd like
to point out on the amendment which i
like better than the original bill
um
is that it doesn't uh tell the public
housing what they have to do
it just
and
it
tells the towns to ensure public housing
has access to the appropriate
site for composting et cetera
representative and representative
manager putin
i believe that you have to talk to the
housing authority
and they probably will have to get
permission from hud
and i think it you'd wait for an answer
for a long time
i i really don't you know i've worked
for the housing authority
and they don't allow any of this stuff
nothing
if your cars broke down they're gonna
have a towed out you know they're real
stringent on the rules
thank you representative majipuni
thank you mr chair
just looking at the opportunity equal
opportunity
just because
citizens are living in a housing
authority and want to do the right thing
it shouldn't be
such a hard
climb
to have this opportunity to compost or
do the right thing
even though they are you know this
if
it's not available it to me it is a
discriminatory
practice so
i am
you know
one rule for one
so this is public housing and to bring
in not every community has composting
not everybody has a citywide composting
so this is a good start
and so i mean i know nashua has a
private
curbside
paid composting and if that is working
well it might look at
adopting citywide if it's not going to
cost the city more
right so we have to look at the good
practices and see how that could be so
just that my comment thank you
representative guthrie
thank you mr chair it seems to me that
the comments that have been made so far
has shown that the elephant in the room
really is the same old shell
and that since the amendment has still
has shell in it although as indicated
the intent is there i cannot
support
either the amendment or the bill
because of the fact that it's
it
is not may it doesn't have any
flexibility it's a shell so
i just think that that's the elephant in
the room and for whatever reason i
uh other reasons i cannot
vote for the amendment representative
ayer you have an additional comment
yes i uh i worry about animals they're
putting food out and all kinds of things
like that in the compost pile
i would worry
about rats and
other animals you know in the area
representative power
thank you mr chair while i appreciate
the intent of this bill it appears to me
that this is an unfunded mandate and
that that concerns me
okay thank you
representative
it seems to me that the elephant is
rather amorphous
all right i have a
comment
one thing representative gallery it
doesn't appear that you have a
well
you don't have any co-sponsors at least
published on this
so i'm i'm a little concerned about
uh what the rest of the community that
we deal with feels about this it's like
a single point
solution
and
when you when we look at composting
i do composting it and i know that
a cop my composting pile takes about the
entire summer
for it to
turn over and
turn into a fertilizer and so forth
so and we've been mixing in discussions
about weekly pickups
and or our periodic pickups of the of
the composting
so
i'm thinking that uh
that we might need some time with uh
with the state
uh and their engineers to talk about
what what is the right frequency uh
what are the right locations
we heard a representative talk about
drawing animals in
and and i'm not talking about animals of
the good type
so
how we deal with that is it do you need
to put poison out to accommodate them
and
what are the implications to local
children with that so
what i'm reflecting back to you is that
it seems to me be a lot of unanswered
questions with this
so that's my airport yes representative
thank you mr chair i'm a tad concerned
that you specifically spoke directly to
the sponsor of the bill
and questioned his
ability to enter a bill with or without
co-sponsors
what does it matter if he has any
co-sponsors well uh that's a good point
my thought is that uh when when you have
a lot of co-sponsors on a on a
piece of legislation that is
its virgin if you will to the
to the
uh legislature it helps to know
that this isn't just one of four hundred
this is one of several that have that
have thought about this
you know i don't know how
kawasa county feels about it i don't
know about belknap county
about the people over in keene do they
want to do this
i i just i'm looking for more input
i don't mean to be criticizing
the representative i think
someone already said that
this is a great idea
i've my thought is it's just not well
thought through
and i think it would help
if you had
seven or eight people sitting around the
table
either all reps or representatives of
the state to discuss this and put issues
on the table and work through them and
then you'd you you'd get you'd come back
and you'd have some lessons to learn
well we talked to this and that and
here's what they said and
and we get to stop doing this first and
you know that those are very valuable
discussions if you can capture them yes
for everything that's davis
thank you mr chair and what you
described just perfectly is interim
study
and i wonder why this bill can't be
afforded the same dignity
as the other bills of the same ilk
and go to interim study it it seems to
me
that the
ability to compost one's food should not
be dependent upon where ones lives are
one circumstances in life
that if if the date determines the
guidelines for such composting
then they should be
carried out statewide
and and why this bill can't go to
interim study with the other bills of
the same sort would be a mystery to me
because you just described it eloquently
thank you representative
thank you again mr chair and thank you
representatives davis for pointing that
out i i would just add that
we are currently in the mode of adopting
the amendment so should we want to get
to
interim study we need to act on this
first
and then go forward apologies no apology
necessary thank you yes representative
um this is not about the bill but i'm
asking about your comment just to ask
the question of the chair
you alluded to
single sponsor bill this uh prime
sponsor is only one sponsor we just
passed a bill 1070 with one single
sponsor and we had a robust debate so
i'm just trying to understand
where your comment about just one
sponsoring one bill a bill with just
single sponsor
so i'm just i'm a little confused
if you could yes i i hear you
i was trying to offer some constructive
advice to the representative
uh as
as we consider new legislation
uh it's helpful to have inputs from
from others as well
representative gallagher
um and just kind of asked the
counterpart to um
representative manjapudi's comment about
um yes we have passed
bills with only single sponsors before
we've also
voted down
bills with large lists of sponsors um
11 1119 the um bill to
allow municipalities to
regulate single-use plastic bags that
had a giant list of sponsors and the
majority of the committee still it's
certainly not a a uh
perfect science
but take my advice for what it's worth
yes representative
thank you mr chair i'm gonna be that
pain in the neck that i was yesterday
and call the question
please and thank you is there uh
is there any objection to us moving
forward with this amendment
okay
we have an amendment
on the floor
this is
bill hb 1172 fn
i'm sorry the amendment number is help
me mister
the amendment number is 2022-0658
h thank you so we're voting on the
amendment would you call the roll
yes mr chairman
uh
vice chairman pm monty
uh yes
clerk votes yes
representative tripp i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative losalis
yes
representative fleet
what do you mean yes i'm sorry yes
uh representative melvin
yes
representative ayer
representative power
representative majori
yes
representative 311 yes please
representative gilman
representatives davis yes
representative megapootie yes
representative
yes
representative clee
representative gallagher
yes representative ron yes
and chairman dolan
no
yeses and two narrows
17 to 2.
mr chairman yes
since we have adopted the
amendment i would like to recommend that
this bill go to interim study
interim study for hb
1172 fn
discussion
seeing none would you call the role
you had a question representative
when you want to talk to us
yes sir representative thank you for the
reminder
okay uh hb
1172 the motion is
interim study
vice chairman
pia monty
no
clerk votes now
uh
representative tripp
no
representative guthrie
representative
los alas
yes
uh representative plant
no
representative melvin no
representative here
representative power no
representative majori yes
representative tray levin
yes representative gilman yes
representative davis yes
representative megaputi
yes
representative vann yes
representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
representative rung yes
and chairman dolan yes
uh motion passes 11 to 8.
okay thank you uh so we just passed the
amendment now we have
you just passed interim study
i'm sorry i went right to interim study
excuse me mr chair yes
what was that count eleven eight or ten
to nine eleven eight seven eight okay
thank you
our next bill we're going to tackle is
hb 1177 which is relative to
permissible
residential units in a residential zone
okay
thank you
man
representative matt jory would you pick
uh responsibility for the for the
committee report
uh thank you mr chair i believe
representative gallagher
is willing to take the committee report
for 1172 is that correct yes thank you
hey we are about to
take on hb 1177
which has an amendment
it just passed out
so i will
look to
representative vann to make a motion on
the amendment
mr chairman i move that we adopt the
amendment
2022-0562-h
on hb 1177.
would you like to speak to your
amendment yes i would um when we had the
discussion about this bill
uh nate graves from you know hansel new
hampshire municipal association sorry
uh said that he thought that there might
be an issue
with the fact that
we talked about adus in the bill
so since
this is really an issue of how many
units there are
and some of them can be big and some of
them can be small there seem to be no
reason to leave adu language in the bill
so i have removed it
so what it says is you can have up you
can have up to an including four units
which can be configured in a single four
unit building two duplexes a triple unit
or four have four townhouses
or four single units as in a cottage
court
um
and
i recommend that we adopt it
thank you
is there any further discussion on this
bill yes representative again i know
some learning asking questions
does this make a difference whether
there's public water or sewer
or not
well that's not part of the amendment
but i'm happy to ask answer that when we
get to
the underlying bill
okay so are you okay to hold on that
thought
any other discussion on the amendment
yes representative
thank you mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question
uh during the the hearing on
the
bill
uh
a uh
a similar amendment was offered you know
this this amendment seems to be mostly
you know uh housekeeping
uh but i i asked about uh
the question of uh requiring subdivision
uh
because of uh
say the two duplex units
uh
do you believe that
the amendment
removes that
that requirement to subdivide the
property you would only have to
subdivide if you did not set it up to
sell as a condo
what the bill says simply is that
you can build four units
which would be all on one lot
and you can put them in two buildings
or four buildings or
one building
the issue of subdivision has to do with
ownership
and would be handled in a different
place this is just about the number
uh further discussion on the amendment
yes representative loseless
representative van um and i could be uh
um
off base but
the amendment does
talk about served by municipal water and
sewer
but there doesn't seem to be anything in
that language
with respect to capacity
so if if
a municipality
has
municipal water and sewer
but there is a concern about capacity
how would that affect
well that's not germane to the amendment
but i'm happy to answer the question
the the answer is that the statutory
language in new hampshire says
that if a proposal is brought forward to
the planning board they cannot be served
by the existing water and sewer
infrastructure or other infrastructure
including roads and schools
that the town can deny it
any further questions on the amendment
amendment yes representative
uh representative just a quick question
what do you have as a matter of right
in your amendment
it was in the original bill
and i'm happy to talk about that when we
get to the bill okay thank you
representative gilman
thank you mr chair i'd like to point out
that
although this is uh
as a matter right allowing more dwelling
units than perhaps your
residential
zone may have you still have to
um
adhere to any of your zoning that uh
talks about lawton yard setbacks and
parking requirements and lot coverage so
it will be probably be more dividing up
a big single family than it will be
adding new units to
um
to a town
thank you uh yes representative
uh thank you mr chair like i spoke at
the
hearing public hearing
this
you know if you look at all the comments
and stuff and i think representative van
took the feedback from some of the
support adding
you know to
the amendment
but it enables
baby boomers or people like me who want
to age in place to stay in my home and
be able to do that
and this will
will not restrict
so this is a
good thing for
our state and our community
so further comments or questions
representative gallagher did you have
one
um
so
just um
[Music]
to respond to representative mcdonald's
question about the as a matter of fact
um i'm thinking the reason that might
stand out more in the memo is just
because there were commas added around
it even though
the language was there
in the original
um and then also um
so
um
the
description of the amendment was mostly
about the 80s portion but i'm also
seeing
a part
about
um
the parking requirements
and here looks changed from the original
bill um
i'm wondering if representative van
could go more into detail about the
parking requirements
that was actually in the amendment that
we discussed at the original hearing
um there had been some confusion about
the parking so when we
saw this bill initially
on whatever day that was i had already
had an amendment so what we looked at on
i think it was february 7th
was an amended bill that had the parking
requirements spelled out
okay any further discussion no comments
we are voting on the amendment
so mr clerk would you call a roll
okay amendment 2022-05
vice chairman piamonte no
clerk votes no representative tripp
i vote no
representative guthrie
representative losalis
yes
uh representative plett
no
representative melvin no
representative here
no
representative power
representative majority yes
representative tray 11 yes
representative gilman yes
representative stavis yes
representative mangapudi
representative vann
yes
okay
representative clee
representative gallagher
yes
representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan
since the amendment has failed i'd like
to
i'd like to
no but i can speak up
uh since the amendment has failed i
would still like to move ought to pass
on the underlying bill
so that's emotion
so we have a motion is there a second
right here
okay emotion's been made in second it's
a discussion now on the motion ought to
pass i'd like to speak to my move to my
motion
okay so
there was a question about someone asked
about why does it say municipal water
and sewer i'll answer that first there
are two reasons one of which is that it
is in the best interests of our towns
cities and other areas
to encourage further development where
we already have infrastructure that's
the sort of big overall picture the
second thing is that in terms of
financing um a four-unit building
it is very difficult not to say
impossible to get financing from a bank
for a multi-unit building that does not
have water and sewer so that's the
answer to that
and um i am aware that this is an uphill
battle but
for 40 years the state of new hampshire
has
has depended on the kindness of
individual towns and cities to provide
housing
that has left us more than 20 000 units
short
if we continue
to leave it up to local control this is
only going to get worse
what happens when you have a desirable
place
and a limited supply of housing
is that that limited supply is taken by
the people with the most money which is
fine for them but it's a little hard on
everyone else who needs to live there
one question we need to ask ourselves is
how far is it reasonable to ask a
bartender to drive home after her shift
if she can't live in the town where she
works
this is not a new idea
uh limiting allowing limited number
limited size
of multi-families this is what's called
the missing middle
and we used to allow it we have plenty
of examples of it still in existence
but we can't build any more of it
if we maintain our single-family only
zone
does this mean that you can't build a
single-family house no it doesn't it
means that you have more choices
than simply a single family fewer than
20 percent of all households in the
united states consist of a mother and a
father and some children in school
i will representative gallagher could
you click off your mic please
please continue
by the year
2025 we expect more than 60 percent of
all households to be one in two-person
households we've over-provided big
single-family households and
under-provided every other form of
housing for the last 60 years we have
artificially constrained the production
of
housing one of the things that has come
up in the last few years is there's been
quite a lot of research including a uh
research project that was just con
concluded
by the josiah bartlett institute which
says that
when one town
votes
to make their zoning more restrictive to
recovery
require more
a larger lot longer frontages
less coverage all of those things what
happens is that the towns around it
also adopt that and often become even
more restrictive it's a death spiral and
we have seen what has happened
i've been looking at housing and local
local votes in new hampshire since 1982.
we're not making any progress
this is not a novel idea it's been done
other places it simplifies the ability
to get a loan
the federal
housing administration considers a
fourplex a house
a fourplex is a house you get a plain
beige vanilla loan for up to four units
this is not the kind of development that
attracts big out of town developers this
is the kind of development that can be
done by two women in a pickup truck
it can be done by a little old woman who
lives in a house that's too big for her
it can be done by a young couple who
can't quite cover the mortgage with
their jobs
they can make a conversion
rent out that house
i don't know what else to say
the
housing advocates favor this vote the
new hampshire business and industry
favors this bill the new hampshire
business review wrote a long laudatory
article about this bill
the uh
the builders like this bill even though
as i said it's not a big bill for them
the real estate agents like this bill
the people on the far right like this
bill
the people who are worried about housing
like this bill
i just hate to see us
decide
that we don't care
and that's what we're going to be doing
it's not going to get better if we don't
do
something
the rich get richer
and the poor live in their cars
thank you
representative
thank you very much mr chair and i think
we all can see how passionate
representative van is about this issue i
seconded this motion
and i voted in favor of the adopting the
amendment
because i'm a real estate broker i've
been a real estate broker for over 30
years and i see this on the ground just
like i see the trash
right on the ground i see this at the
level of individuals attempting to have
homes for their families in communities
i see that
young
couple who wants to buy a duplex or a
four-plex so they can raise their family
in it and have some income to help
support the maintenance of the building
and they want to be in the community
i think this is an incredibly positive
insightful
and exciting opportunity for the state
of new hampshire
the idea that you can get a
non-commercial loan
on a four unit building
is
brilliant it's very difficult to get a
commercial loan if you're not a business
person it's very easy to get this kind
of loan if you're employed and you have
a little bit of money for a down payment
and and you can move forward
and keep that building in the housing
stock
in the town that it's in i drove by all
those buildings the what's it called the
missing middle on my way here this
morning not from my house
the places i drove by
from my house to the main highway are
the places that could be the missing
middle
the ones that have
water and sewer provided by the
community that could have an apartment
that could have another small building
that could be made into two units
because they're so big
when i got to concord i drove by the
missing middle that already exists here
and it's all around us it's all those
big beautiful victorian buildings that
were converted over time because they
were too big for the families
and people needed to live here and
people want to work here so i i am just
a hundred percent in support of this
bill and if you have any real estate
questions that i might answer i would be
happy to do so thank you so much mr
chair sure representative
thank you mr chair
um
i know this is
i'm looking
at my emails and thank you
representative van for bringing up
joshua
bartlett center public policy
study this was also referred to i mean
we just got an email from
a prime sponsor of another bill which
tries to address
that is hb 1238 in terms of increasing
the housing stock
and this
you know even if i look at just my
personal situation
where in my neighborhood which has 36
single family homes
4 out of 36 has already added
a in-law apartment
to their unit to bring their aging
parents
to
live with them
and
i am getting there and i want my
children to be able to live in the same
building or my dwelling so that i could
age gracefully in my own home and in my
own community where i have lived for 30
plus years
so this
addresses many issues missing middle
aging in place
and the acute shortage that we have in
terms of housing
nashua city of nashua has
five
thousand
five three zero units shortage in a
population of ninety thousand people
and so that you know this is such a
critical need
and like uh representative ryan alluded
to
if we don't offer a roof over a head
people poor people that are working two
full-time jobs to adults live in a car
because they can't afford and there is
no
housing available
so this is a critical need and i would
wholeheartedly support and please look
at
and this is not overburdening
the communities that don't have rural
communities to maintain the character if
there's no public sewer and
water
this does not apply to it
so
you know with that i would seriously
consider the merits in much needed
housing that we need
yesterday not tomorrow thank you
representative gilman
thank you mr chair uh
representative manjapudi covered a
little bit of what i wanted to say
um
this does i think this bill although i i
liked the amendment better um
provides for the need that we have but
doesn't impose
the look of
a town unless uh somebody's really
aggressive about development and
there's the you know people have their
hair on fire that their two-acre zoning
is going to be ruined by this but a lot
of two-acre zoning isn't supported by
water and sewer
so that rural essence will will remain
um and i i think this does a lot i think
that the constraints of having to meet
the lot
requirements that are currently in place
in every town that has zoning ordinances
really
have limit
what you can do yet get more housing
thank you mr chair
yes representative lasallas
thank you mr chairman um
in my own
history here short term history
i've actually been a co-sponsor of a
bill that was
it was geared toward
increasing workforce housing
so i've been very consistent in
supporting
things that i feel would would improve
the situation here in
in new hampshire
we're in a situation now
where the lack of housing
particularly workforce housing
is a
detriment
to the overall long-term
growth of the economy
in new hampshire
there's almost never a day when you turn
on the news
that this crisis that we have
is not
present on the news
just this morning i heard that that an
employer
here in new hampshire is actually
building housing
for their employees
it has gotten to that point they have
valued employees who can't get housing
the employer is actually building the
housing
i think this bill
with the requirement of
municipal water and sewer
is not is of little danger
to
changing the rural character
of
the overwhelming
uh
part of municipalities within the state
so
with all of that being said i will be
supporting this
yes
i'm sorry representative
thank you mr chair
representative lasalle
must be watching the same tv show be
news because uh i it was i think the
lead-off story last week last night
and just last thursday we heard from
governor sununu about how the housing
crisis is impacting the health and the
future of our state
this committee
we are best situated of anybody in state
government right now at this moment to
address that
um so i want to reiterate what my
colleague from litchfield said
the other thing about this bill is
owners on site
um
typically in something like this the
owner lives there and is able to be
responsive so it raises the whole
quality of the housing and the quality
of life for people that
are inhabiting that housing
and um
i this isn't really going to apply much
to merrimack because we don't have much
housing that's served by both water and
sewer
but i can tell you i walk through
my neighborhood before my my knee issue
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
in-law apartments on houses that you
really don't see and they're rented out
they would not be
allowed under here we already allow
multiple family housing without this as
long as it's rented to someone that's in
the family so i don't see how this is
going to impact
what our perception of what we want to
be
as much as we think it is
and when you really get down to it it is
about private property owner rights
people own that property and if if they
meet these these
requirements
why should we tell them no you can't add
on an apartment or you can't add on on
three other apartments those people own
that own that land that's their land
that they should be able to do what they
want to do with it as long as it meets
current zoning requirements and building
codes which is in this bill so i
wholeheartedly support it i encourage my
colleagues to do the same thank you
representative
thank you mr chair for recognizing me
again and thank you for your comments um
the commentary regarding television show
made me
remember something i want to tell you a
little story
very short i drove out of town yesterday
and i drove on a side street i think
it's called park street and it's part of
a church and there's a homeless
community there
houseless community lots and lots of
people out in the parking lot in the wet
in the cold with all their belongings in
their shopping carts
arguing trying to do something with the
cardboard to separate it out and
my heart was breaking as i was driving
by i took myself home and my husband and
i were watching
public television last night and there
was a program on about workhouses
and what workhouses were is where we put
houseless people
in the 18th and early 19th century and
for your voluntary imprisonment they
called it labor
you got a bed
three meals a day and a place to sleep
considering what i saw in the morning or
early afternoon and what i saw on that
television show
my husband and i kind of looked at each
other and said
you know that work house doesn't seem
like a bad deal considering the
alternatives what we're doing right now
leaving people
out in the cold
to face the elements
with nowhere to go
i just wanted you to have that in your
head while you think about voting on
this bill thank you representative tripp
thank you for allowing me to speak on
this
i know i mentioned
to a number of you that i don't own a tv
so i'm sorry that i haven't been able to
keep up with the documentaries
uh
one of the problems
with this bill
is it does speak to
uh requiring
water and sewage
but it doesn't speak to
the adequacy
uh
of
it in a town
i i would
imagine that uh
should this be adopted
then uh there'll be a number of units
that are converted from you know the old
houses into
the four
residential dwelling units but
as i said there's there's no mention of
any
increased density
uh which would require
more water and sewage
mentioned here
uh
so that's an issue with the bill
another issue that i had was
this assumes that
all these
residential dwelling units are going to
be either owner occupied
or
some
form of a rental
or a condominium
uh
the uh if not
then
there's going to be
subdivision required
since you can't own
uh
you can have two buildings
uh on a single lot
that are not owned by the same person uh
could you answer some of those questions
yes i'd be delighted to all of those
issues are taken up other places in the
land usage statutes two buildings can be
owned by two different people on a
single plot of land
if you want to sell it you can
condominiumize it condo condos are a
form of ownership you can make a condo
out of your bread box if you want to if
you can get someone to live there and i
think there might be people who are
ready to move into a bread box
uh and as to the water and sewer as i've
said
over and over again there is language in
the statute which allows
communities to deny a development based
on inadequate services which includes
water and sewer also if you're
converting a house and your
water pipe is not adequate
then the town will require you to
replace it if they don't have water for
you they will say
you can't do this because there's not
enough water here
they have the right to deny
based on those issues i really do think
that that's not a concern and
additionally there is all of that
language elsewhere
in the land use statutes that address
the issues that you have raised
and i'd like to add one other thing
which i think i forgot to say in my
little jimmy stewart speech for you
we uh
we talk a lot about local control and
not wanting to take away local control
we already take away local control
about issues having to do with hazardous
waste water supply
septic
garbage
witness the things we had this morning
about solid waste disposal those are all
things that are designed decided at the
state and they have one thing in common
which is they affect the common good
of the entire state
i would argue that providing adequate
housing
for our citizens is about the baseline
of the common good
thank you uh further discussion
representative
thank you mr chair
just if i look at
the taxes based on a single family home
we have four bathrooms
so our taxes is based on how many
bathrooms
we have in a single family home
so
considering that there are four
bathrooms
in the house to convert that into a four
plux
in terms of water usage wastewater
it doesn't change for the tax purposes
or the zoning purposes just looking at
my own situation
so i mean we may not be using all um
four bathrooms but we are paying taxes
for all four bathrooms
we are paying uh you know our usage
based on the use of the things so
this really does not
affect
in terms of
public
sewer and water supply which already
exists
in a single family with a specific lot
and so i think without having to change
major structure
you know it would help somebody like me
to say i can afford because i get calls
every day from the university that's
close by can you house a uh student
right now we cannot other than if i take
them and as my family member to uh house
them or you know
so many professionals that are moving in
they can't find a place
there's a is there a place to uh hold so
this
allows
people who currently exist in a single
family home
to age in place gracefully and
be part of a community and grow the
community that i want to see
that i want to be part of and not have
to move out of the community that i live
right now
thank you
did you hear
i take the prerogative of our haunted
guests and i move the question
mr chair i'd actually like to say
something further before we move the
questions
to be uh made on this
i would actually like to say you get the
last word the power of the last word
um one of the things that i noticed when
we exec when we had the hearing on this
bill was who showed up to talk for it
we had a developer come and say i'd
actually like to build this kind of
housing but right now i can't because my
zoning doesn't allow it
i talked to
people from the real estate agencies
from the builders
all of them thought that this was a bill
that could increase our housing supply
without
damaging the character of our places
these are house sized buildings
it's quite clear in the bill that you
can't build a 150 unit garden apartment
you can build a building that is the
same size as a house
it's just a house
i think that it is
i think it's astonishing that we have
not already
made some strides in this direction
manchester 79 of manchester is owned
single-family only in spite of the
presence of all of those historic triple
deckers
four plexes dignified small apartment
buildings they're illegal you can't
build any more of them
even though those are some of the
neighborhoods we love best
and that people want to live in
this part of the crisis that we're
having is because the kinds of places
that everyone wants to live almost
everyone many people let's put it that
way
are the places we're not building any
more of
walkable places where my eight-year-old
can ride her bicycle and buy a popsicle
where my 84 year old mother-in-law can
walk and buy a quart of milk
those places are expensive
because we're not making any more
i suggest that we allow those places to
grow in a historically appropriate way
thank you uh representative
uh yeah i um
um
i know there were a number of reasons
why
um
there was restrictions on certain
building and building areas
there had to be a reason for it
um just the last
bill of the bill before that we were
talking about local control and we were
kind of
you know saying there wasn't enough
local control we had to
uh do something and now we have too much
local control and they want to take it
away from that
um i know the nhma if i'm not mistaken
opposed this bill and they said that it
was
basically um not ready
uh not prime time or something like
someone along mostly i'm sorry
yeah
and that was because of thanking
representative gilman because the adus
so um
that's really all i have to say on that
i think local control should stay as low
control
and let the towns decide whether cities
decide where they're going with it
again we are legislating
something
that allows them to do what
they would do according to this bill but
again
it does take away from the contract yes
it does oh sorry i thought you had waved
at me
i'm going to uh
use the chairman's privilege here to
call on one other person that i need i'd
like to hear from
and that's representative
in your
travels around in conducting your
business
in
real estate
i'm sure you're you're observing
a lot of different things i'd like to
hear from you
how you feel about
the issue of zoning how it impacts
uh housing availability and
um
the use of adu is if there if the
if
people are actually using them as we
design as we design the legislation
around them and just like to get your
anecdotal
response
mr chair thank you so much for the
question i feel like my
experience in the trenches is paying off
right at this very moment
in answer to your second question first
people are absolutely using the
opportunity to put in an adu
in the property they already own and
they're absolutely using the opportunity
to look for a property in which an adu
could be added now or in the future and
they're thinking of all of the
generations that we were talking about
representative manjuputi
children parents and grandparents very
multi-generation generational
housing opportunities and people are
really looking for that
in
in the in the context of the market
right now
um
you know as a seller you may think it's
a lot of fun to get multi offers well
it's not because you're deciding on
someone else's future and you've got
eight people sitting in front of you and
it's pretty painful process to pick one
and those people are all looking for the
same thing
a nice place to live somewhere for their
family to be
something they can afford and something
that they will stay in for quite a while
i i don't see i see people who are
flippers who are investors but not as
many as there used to be
in answer to the
second part of your question could you
remind me of what you said at the
beginning because now i lost my train of
thought it was
the impact of zoning oh thank you yes um
the impact of zoning is huge
on towns cities municipalities
some of what
we see in
smaller towns and communities used to be
referred to and may still be by some
people and you're not supposed to say
this as snob zoning
meaning they require a large lot so only
somebody with a lot of money or
resources behind them could purchase
that lot
that seems to be going out of favor
although they're not rezoning those
places
they are what they are going forward
towns are more
towns and cities are more
amenable to looking at what is called
cluster zoning
or a pud which is a planned unit
development which is a circle or a
square or a couple of circles or squares
of houses with empty with conservation
land around that so you have more open
space
the same number of houses just on a on a
building lot so zoning definitely
affects it
and oh there was something else i wanted
to say and now it's gone again
i think that this bill um
allows cities and towns
to make their own decisions based on
their building codes and based i mean
the state building code obviously
overrides but
not but yet in their building codes and
their zoning codes and what they want
their community to look like um the
market is definitely out there for this
sort of building big developers want to
do big developments and i don't fault
them at all they that's how they make
money we all make a living
small developers meaning that you know
mom and pop shop who
live in barrington but they own a house
which is a duplex in dover and they
maintain that house you know that's
their retirement income and the more
that we can do that for people and then
they could retire there in dover sell
the house in barrington because they
don't need a big single family anymore
and
going forward sorry i was long-winded
thank you uh i value your inputs and
i think i learned something thank you
yes
representative ayer
i agree with
taking older big houses
and making apartments out of them
i like the idea that you can walk to the
store
but what i'm afraid of as you pass this
bill it's for the whole state
so if there's a small lot in your town
that's been a lot forever but it's tiny
and you have a nice ranch house on this
side and a nice one on this side and you
just live in there someone can come in
and put a four unit building right
between them
and i want to know how many people in
this room
are willing to have a brand new four
unit apartment
house next to their house
that's that's a good question but i'm
not going to pull the committee on uh mr
chairman i just want to i'd actually
like to respond to that when i get a
minute representative davis that had a
comment
trying to remember what it was
but um
yes now i remember
i wanted to address representative
tripp's concern about water and sewer
and i serve on um a large planting boat
that serves a very large city lebanon
and we have in fact denied
applicants
that want to put up developments that
exceed our utility capacity our water
and sewage capacity we have denied those
and we don't need the legislature's
permission to do that
it's in our current
local
zoning regs
that are supported by state statute so
that
just to you know put your mind at ease
about the water and sewage issue and the
second point i wanted to make really a
point is just an
anecdote which is that i live
in
what i guess you would call the planned
unit development it's single-family
homes it's a lot of single-family homes
really close together
and when it was built 22 years ago
it was about the most controversial
thing in the city of lebanon and now
there are waiting lists for people
wanting to buy those homes it is it's
the hottest place to live in the entire
upper valley
and so i support this bill
we need more housing the housing that
will be built
if this bill passes
will be done by most likely by local
craftspeople local laborers bringing
more jobs to more people
and as i've always said
home is where jobs go to sleep at night
and if we want to keep our workers in
the state if we want to keep our
grandparents and our grandkids in the
state
it's just as simple as two plus two
equals four they need places to live
thank you uh representative van impe yes
i just have one last thing to say which
is oh sorry can i ask you just keep it
sure it is uh to the question about
would i want a four unit building next
to me
i'll remind you that the bill says that
that building can't be any bigger than a
single family house and it has to
provide the same amount of parking per
unit
as a single family house does so i would
argue that if that lot is small they
can't get a four unit four units on it
because they're going to exceed the lot
coverage lots of towns have a 35 percent
lot coverage requirement
if you've got
an 8 000 square foot lot of record that
means that you can't build a building
that is bigger than you know the house
that would fit on it it's pretty small
thank you um
thank you mr chair i've been listening
very intently to to all the inputs here
and i just had a quick question what is
the um typical or
typical amount of parking for a single
family home i'm just curious
what's the number
two
i just wanted to answer the parking
question most cities towns and villages
have repo have an off-street parking
requirement of two
uh stalls of off-street parking per unit
which actually means that that's another
constraint on this production because
lots of lots that might accommodate a
house
won't accommodate the parking so instead
of getting four units you'll only get
two
okay thank you out of respect for
representative guthrie we're going to
move the question
so let's uh
try to remember where we are
we are considering
hb 1177
and we have a motion
on the table to otp
not for the amendment this is otp
without the amendment
so
mr clerk would you call the roll
thank you mr chairman uh otp in 1177
vice chairman pmit
no
click votes no
representative chip
no
representative guthrie yes
representative silas
yes
representative platt
no
representative melvin no
representative
here representative power no
representative midrory yes
representative
yes
representative gilman yes
representative stavis yes
representative megaputi
yes
representative vann yes
representative clee sorry uh
representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan
and chairman dolan
motion passes
10 to 8.
so the next item on our agenda
mr chair i just wanted to note that i
believe representative van will probably
write the majority report for that
if you don't already have that volume in
your possession
thank you for coming to my ted talk
okay we're gonna next uh move on to
something that's a little different
it's hb 1179
relative to zoning protest petitions
mr chairman yes i'd like to make a
motion to itl
motion is there a second
okay
discussion
seeing none did did
representative van were everybody out
okay
uh mr clerk would you call the roll
this is 1179 for itl
vice champion monty
yes
clerk votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative silas
yes representative mcbride
uh sorry
uh representative plate yes
my apologies representative
just changed my name
it already takes me a couple of weeks to
get it down so uh representative melvin
yes
representative here yes
representative power
yes
weaponism majority representative tray
representative gilman yes representative
davis yes
representative mega poody yes
representative fan yes
representative klee
i wasn't here when the voted vote
started so i don't believe i can vote
thank you
thank you uh representative gallagher
no
representative wrong yes
and shannon dolan yes
the 17 to one
okay without without objection i'll
put that on the consent calendar
and our next item is
house bill 1183
or
depending on how
the committee feels we can take a break
for lunch
i'll second that we have a motion and a
second on the floor to itl house bill
is there
is there a second
yeah
okay is there any discussion on this on
1183 before we vote
seeing none i'd ask the clerk to call a
roll on 1183
okay the motion is italian 1183 uh vice
chairman pmonty yes
collect votes yes
representative tripp
yes
i i think uh we have a problem with the
uh
although now it seems to be working
john's not working
your microphone's not working
you can hit that one or this one over
here
[Music]
yes
uh
representative plutt yes
representative melvin
yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majorie yes
representative yes
representative gilman yes
representative stavis yes
representative megan footy yes
representative
yes representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
representative
yes
and uh chairman dolan yes
18-0
motion passes
and what was the the
prior vote was 17-2 is that right
okay without objection we'll put the
1183 on the consent calendar
you want to keep going
yeah okay
11.94
i'm sorry 1184
is the next bill we're going to take up
1184 has been moved to itl is there a
second
representative melvin second
is there any discussion on the on the
house bill 1180
is there any discussion on it yes
representative gallagher
um this is
authorizing the establishment of
revolving funds correct that seemed like
a reasonable idea
to me so i would like to hear
some reasons as to why
people oppose it if
they're willing to do so
well we haven't had
anybody declare their opposition to the
uh to the bill yet
but we do have a motion to itl
would anybody like to take
representative gallagher's challenge up
yes representative
yes i feel that we shouldn't be telling
towns
what they can do with their money
i think we're interfering with their
budgets and everything else
um if i may respond um i believe this is
enabling legislation which
means we're not telling them
it means we're not telling them what
they can do
with their budgets we're just giving
them another option of things that they
can't do
mr chair
this committee
just maybe an hour ago
voted for a mandate about telling towns
what to do with their default budgets
mr chair yes representative tripp
during the hearing on this bill
i uh
found several clericals in the bill
and uh
it was agreed that they were clericals
and uh i don't see an amendment so this
bill
is still flawed
that's why
i
am against it
okay representative
majori
thank you mr chair um
i am going to vote oppose the itl
we are
as we learn simply matching language
which exists in statute already in rsa
so that counties
cities and village districts can have
the authority to create a revolving fund
for the
for better fiscal management it seems to
me that this bill
is even a bit of housekeeping that makes
an awful lot of sense and i would hope
that the
committee would vote against the itl so
another motion can be made thank you
representative
thank you mr chair
um
this is
we just talked about the elephant in the
room the word shall
if i look at the spill
i don't see shell
i see may a county may a city may
a may is an enabling
bill and gives the authority local
authority to establish a revolving fund
as
needed
to that community
and if we really honor and cherish and
enable
the local authority this is the bill to
support so with that in mind
this is my first term but i'm learning
fast in terms of what this committee
does
and so this is an enabling bill and i
would be voting against itl
and so
uh we can
make another motion
yes representative
uh thank you mr chair mr chair in my my
notes
there's no amendment on this correct in
in my notes on page
line 27
i
i circled the word county's general
surplus
to say that that should be cities
and then on page
line 24 i've circled that word of
counties part of the county's general
surplus that it should be village was an
amendment brought forward on this
no
does the way it reads is this going to
be an issue
i'm sorry
that's okay
page 2
line 27
the the
word county part of the county's general
surplus i had written a note that it
should be
cities
and then on page 3
line 24 it also circled that
that it should be village um
as
i'm still trying to learn a lot of the
differences between villages and cities
and
and and towns and so on does it make a
difference that the word county is in
there right does anybody
mr chair yes having
i sit on the county
uh
what do you call it
delegation or executive uh committee uh
and
county also has a
surplus or revolving fund
cities have this applies to all
municipalities at all levels so this is
an enabling for all levels
to
establish that so
may i follow up sir yes thank you um i i
think um
representative manjapuri missed my point
i may have just made a mistake in in my
notes um when i wrote that because as
i'm reading it i do think it says that
it should not be considered part of
any of the counties so that that is my
my error um
then i'd like to speak to the um
to the bill itself um
i also had written in here that this was
a housekeeping bill as
the previous representative had
mentioned
and that um this is already in existence
for towns and this just brought in
cities and villages etc am i correct on
that as well
i can't trust my notes these days
we have to ask the
thank you mr chair so um based on the
notes that i took during the hearing
presently
counties do not have revolving funds as
seen in the bill framework on page one
line one it's a completely new section
additionally there's a new section on
page two line six
pertaining to city revolving funds
in which um there are new purposes um
added
additionally
we heard in testimony
well let me just back up
i do have concerns about there are some
clerical errors and i'm concerned
that that was pointed out and no
amendment has been brought forward to
correct those errors
so
additionally
the comment was made during the hearing
that this bill is not ready for prime
time
i would also like to add that rsa 44
cities you know already have revolving
funds it's already established in
statute
this bill adds additional purposes
relative to revolving funds
rsa 52 village districts
my understanding is that section of
statute addresses revolving funds for
for purposes for village districts and
we're just adding more purposes with
this bill
and the other comment the last comment
that i will make
during the hearing as it was stated that
counties do not have in general the need
for
the purposes of revolving
any other funds
yes representative ron
thank you um when this bill came to us
for public hearing i
uh got in touch with the town manager of
merrimack
and
he we use a we have a revolving fund to
manage our rec programs where we
get receipts in from people that are
signing their children up for programs
and then those re those receipts are
then used for expenses it works very
effectively
i think if there are
clerical errors maybe we could put this
bill on hold and give
time for an amendment to be prepared
it's enabling legislation i think it
just increases the efficiency of
government operations as we've seen in
merrimack i really don't think this is a
big deal
okay thank you
any other
inputs
one option we have is to recess the bill
and then assign someone to go to ols and
get an amendment to fix the
issues that we might have with it
any discussion
i'm just discussing dates we're looking
at the dates to see what uh what we can
get done before the cutoff hits
so
well
if someone went today to do it
it's impossible before three
o'clock okay it looks like we have a
little better than three hours
so if
if we can get somebody to take
a draft of this mark it up with the
clerical errors that need to be fixed
then it must be noticed
before three
all right and then it has to be noticed
to the clerk
before three and then we can put in the
calendar we can put it in the calendar
for
our next uh
mr chairman point point of order uh we
have two days scheduled
two executive session days scheduled for
next week could we not take it up then
rather than today
no you don't have to notice executive
sessions
you can do them at any time
you are correct we don't have to notice
the executive session right i'd be
willing to take the markup over to the
to ols and get it done if that would be
helpful
i don't mind doing that until we take a
lunch break
yeah tell me what you want um
does somebody have a list of the
representative power do you have it
somebody have a list of the things we
want fixed i have a couple of things
representative clee also took some notes
as well okay i'll check with both of you
all right thanks
yes so procedural question do you have a
motion of itl on the floor
uh should that be withdrawn uh if we
recess it yeah we should withdraw it and
then take a recess
what was the ideal motion made by a
representative yeah
and seconded by melvin
by representative melvin will you two
gentlemen uh withdraw your
your emotions so we can get this
clean up okay thank you
both both the
primary and the
yellow motion was uh was
withdrawn
so
that gives us a chance to get this
updated
and
i thank you representative band for
volunteering
seemed only fair
and representative power do you have
enough information and representative
clee enough information to provide the
changes that we need to have done
mr chair wasn't uh representative tripp
also was the one who raised that first
do you have any
you asked for clerical errors so would
that
would you have any that uh you wanted to
point out representative trump uh the
the two that uh representative klee and
represent power
uh
identified of the two that
i was talking about okay good
all right um you ready for a lunch break
all right
we'll take a recess and be back here at
uh a quarter past at 12 15.
12 30 i'm sorry 12 30. be back at 12
thirty
earlier we put
back here
oh
that would be eleven twenty two
[Music]
11 22.
11 22 we scheduled for after lunch
that was the first bill
authorizing municipalities collecting
resale construction
and demolition
stuff
yes we're gonna ought to pass it
i think was that the motion
not to pass yeah
all right and then
uh then we were looking at
yeah
well that's fine you have to treat me
with respect i'll give you respect you
know
the one that we've we've decided on the
interim study with people is
11 55 11 55 yes
other than that we didn't assign any
subjects we can do that
through
paul smith if you want later it's up to
you
you look at it if you want
i'm gonna have my
i should smoke as a yeah
yes
the hint is it is a sports question oh
well you know i'm terrible that was
known as mongoose
bonus points what year
and what was his sport
none i just gave you two clues
i i i don't know i don't know anything
about sports
no i don't have a tv
tv as a matter of fact
what was the question
the question is who is known as i think
it's a baseball player and what was his
sport
and for extra points what year
i'm not a baseball player
and representative lasalles will tell
you it's not golf well i i didn't think
like
show me the whole shoe
oh you can't see my socks
what can't see my socks i can't see your
socks tell me
they're what
nope
and
a friend of hers sent her
an instagram
late last year
early last year whatever and uh i bought
socks online
and the
pair of socks that kind of swear on him
said
my dog is cool
well i don't have a dog
but he has a dog and when i went to sell
them send them the socks i was still so
mad at them they were women's size
so they're still in my drawer and i
think i finally gave them to the
goodwill because i was like i can't wear
these
all right i'm going to get air
i know
it was bugging me because i wasn't
checking my legs but if i moved
well we're discussing our interests and
he says
representative
said that he prefers
political uh
now myself
i
sometimes
representative gilman will you ever have
a school board
i've never been on school
well i'm i'm running for school board i
probably don't have a prayer
well i uh take on the heritage and
historic district commissions because no
one else will and that's enough that's
two meetings
planning board does that oh and i'm on
the zoning board
wait
okay you're not a board member or
anything
it's confusing because
we have elected
planning boards we have appointed
zoning words you know it's one of these
things that is a little more complex
than people who believe it
now and
because
i've seen some screwed up bills
yeah
are you talking about mine
okay
so trish what's news
well we had a marathon session last
night
she was front and center
all urban yeah
so i'm so tired today
i didn't get home till midnight
you were so wound up
that's what by the time you wind down
it's one o'clock and then i had to get
up at between 5 and 5 30.
it's like uh
my heart is doing these flip flops and
how long
not long
45 minutes maybe
it's not really essential for those in
the west
or way up yeah
but i think i'm i think i'm heading to
i bought that cardia mobile what do you
think of it
well
it works great i didn't hear some
reviews about it yeah
you ever done it no i've never done i'll
bring it okay
the cardiologist doesn't like it because
it's only one
you know one
input yeah i use this yeah yeah exactly
i thought they had the one where you put
the two fingers on yeah one at the end
yes yeah but it's still
considered one input where if they do an
ekg
all over to make sure it's all yeah and
then they average and they
they look for unusual i mean my oxygen
is really up there which is a good thing
um but my heart rate is like right now
120.
and i can feel those little extra beats
going on right now so
first understand making me sweat
i understand the problem
64 degrees outside
i'm gonna shut his microphone off
in february
um
you can't use tax money anymore so
all right
my name is tom dolan i'm the chair of
the municipal and county government
committee
we
our schedule today this afternoon looks
like we're going to take up our spills
and we need to put a
a bow on
hb 11 84.
[Music]
i'm sorry i was talking to
um yeah so
before lunch we recessed
house bill 1122 until after lunch
so i believe that's something we need to
address as well
okay
thanks for the reminder
do you have it
that we completed it
eleven twenty two
yeah right here
oh
okay on hb 1184
uh representative van is chasing an
amendment for us
so we'll take that up uh later as the
amendment comes in
hb
or i'm sorry hb 1122
is one that we didn't finish
this is the one authorizing
municipalities to collect and resell
construction debris
i'm going to open up to the floors as to
who has additional input they want to
make on this
mr chair
yes
um
are we still
are we still at otp on that bill or we
was there no motion
we're still at otp okay i just want to
know thank you
let's let the clerk
help us out all right
don't mess with him
he's our he's our uh paperwork jedi
okay we
okay
then uh
yes we are at uh
well we were kind of
stuck on
the discussion about uh
how much material would a town like
claremont be forced to take
and
what would we do
is there any any
any hole in the legislation that would
allow us allow claremont to say no we've
had enough or yes we want more
or we just don't want your trains coming
by our houses or whatever
so i'm just i'm right now i'm just
feeding feeding your appetite to
jump back into this discussion and uh
have it out
yes
mr chair i'm trying to remember the
conversation this morning wasn't this
authorizing legislation to allow didn't
force anybody to do anything
it is authorizing legislation yes
i mean enabling legislation
same intent different word
representative gilman yeah i um maybe
shouldn't say this but the town of
exeter already does this
and we have
a transfer station where there are um
uh
whatever they're called
thank you
for the different types of recyclables
like
metals and
wood and
large plastics and
we use waste management as a contractor
and they don't we don't sell the stuff
to them but uh we have a contract with
them and they lower the contract based
on what they get for their tipping fees
so it's not really sale
that's i just wanted to i've been
talking to you call it an opportunity
class i guess yes
representative klee and then
representative tripp
uh thank you mr uh chairman
um
i i know that i put a note here that
suggests um interim study on it but um
if it were ought to pass
it's very it's a one line
um
one or two lines or one sentence i
should say
document here um
based on what representative stavis said
about the trains going by
and this being enabling
i i guess i'm going to ask the question
that's already been asked
would they be able to yeah but would
they be able to
create their own
edict in other words to be able to say
we're only going to take this much and
if we get to a certain point we can stop
and if they enable it
there's nothing
in that in the language that would
prevent that may i ask representatives
davis what her opinion would be on that
see she's the one who brought it up
yes go ahead
oh
thank you for the question and let me
give it a try
um
i think as i said before
freight railroads
fall under the protection of the federal
government
and thus enjoy vast powers
that the state has no
ability to influence
i think you're referring to ferc right
is it ferc ferc is that the the
governing agency
no
um
it could be
no it is not no it's not it's a surface
transportation authority
i believe um
in the city of claremont
there was
a desire to on the heart of a private
rail freight company that enjoys the
protection of the federal government
because it uses the railroad
right-of-way
who haul in and out of the city
24 hours a day seven days a week
hundreds of thousands of tons of
construction debris
the clermont planning board denied
permission for this but it was a long
and difficult difficult struggle we had
we heard from someone at the hearing
from clear clermont testify as to how
long and difficult that struggle is
my point is
the railroads already have as i said
before a leg up on the state
why do we want to give them another
okay
let me suggest that uh
based on that input we just got that's
something to consider when you uh when
you record your vote
yes uh um i want to kind of add to what
representative stavis had said i can
tell you
living in nashville we have the freight
trains come through we recently had one
that stopped for
nine hours
idling by residential areas and there
was nothing we could do about it they
felt that it wasn't safe to go forward
they don't shut those things off because
they're diesel and so on we had no
recourse we had no anything and the
neighbors had to put up with it so i
agree with you they have complete
control and we have none so
based on that i i completely understand
thank you representative tripp
thank you mr chairman
uh
the railroad stories are interesting but
uh this is about uh
transfer stations and what they can
uh accept and and uh how they can
get rid of it i i believe the uh
uh
the purpose of this bill
and i i'm pretty sure that uh uh
representative gilman said that uh
they're unable to sell the construction
degree they have to go through a
middleman and i and i seem to think that
uh
representatives clea said the same thing
so
it appears
that the purpose of this bill
is to
eliminate the middleman
so that uh towns
can uh
put together a contract or whatever
would somebody you know maybe the
railroad i don't know but uh it it'll
eliminate the middleman and allow them
to you know
get all of their revenue from
the construction debris instead of
having to share it with the uh
the middlemen that are
moving off site
and uh
i don't know if if this isn't what the
purpose of the bill is then
you know could you please inform me okay
um
representative majori
thank you mr chair i i just want to
state
i agree the conversation about the
railroad is interesting and if we do
if we do uh have a different vote to go
to interim study i think that would be
interesting however that said
the bill was moved ought to pass
we certainly don't think that the
sponsor is going to object to an ought
to pass motion uh we may have to revisit
the bill it may have to be updated there
may have to be some changes
but if the feeling of this committee is
ought to pass i would bet dimes to
dollars that we're not going to get an
objection from the sponsor so i i i'm
sorry if i've thrown a wrench into the
works a little bit and wanted to pass
that along thank you
okay uh
and i don't see we don't have any
amendments
ending for this
so this is not to pass by itself yes
representative gilman
thank you mr chair one of the questions
that we had i think that is not
currently in the waste
management rsas is that
the line line four of the debris comes
from
a project being completed in town or
from a general contracting business
based in town
and i just wanted to give an example of
what exeter went through
we have a dump
stump dump and brush dump and they were
getting filled up by contractors who
knew
uh they only had to pay five bucks for a
uh with an exeter registered car but
they could do all their business in
kensington and
stratum and elsewhere and we were
getting all of their brush and stumps
until we couldn't move them anymore we
couldn't uh we couldn't handle it
anymore
and we
ended up giving uh having licenses so a
business has to prove that you say
licenses
well not was a license actually um
so the person whose refuse is being
taken away has to sign it that they live
in exeter and then the person who owns
the business has to sign it that they
their business is in exeter so that
that's really controlled the amount of
uh stuff that's been put in our dump
that's that's what they call local
controlling yeah i think so
yes representative tripp
i agree
okay representative
you can agree with me
thank you mr chair i just wanted to add
about the tippage
fee that the municipalities get like
nashua gets at the bridge feeds
typically uh 80 dollars a ton right now
but they limit outside construction
material to come to the dump or for
recycling and you know and we also have
the recycling stream
so there's a different and we had a swap
shop that was not you couldn't resell
but repurpose or reuse that was you know
very
um it stopped so there's also the cost
that you know tippage can go up
there people especially the construction
debris is a big uh
issue in terms of trying to get rid of
so they might be willing to
increase the tippage free
i'm aware of a community that weighs
everything
and charges by the pound yep
yes representative power thank you mr
chair as i recall before the lunch break
pertaining to this bill there was
it was made
it was mentioned
that um there was a commission to study
this issue
and something about gel car rules
so if this bill were to go to an interim
study how would that work in a second
year
in year two
what is the timetable can whoever
brought that up
can you uh
talk to it again and and give us some
more details
yes thank you mr chair and uh and i
certainly appreciate that question and i
wish i had a specific answer to it
um and i can try to get that now in fact
i did just email the sponsor a second
ago to see if he had any extra input on
this i only know that those rules are
coming and or are working through
the process that they have right now
how that process then affects what would
happen in interim study i i can't answer
that specifically except to say
we may have we may get the exact same
bill or we may get a bill that you know
is is improved we may this may go in the
trash i think it could go any one of
those three routes routes depending on
what happens through that process which
is why
i don't think the ought to pass would be
a terrible thing in any way that would
be odd that i'm fighting against it um
but i i don't have a specific answer to
your question follow-up mr chair
yes
yes i agree with all that the
representative stated my question and my
concern is is
if this bill went to an interim study
what is the timeline for the interim
study in year two
of a biennium
because
i just don't understand as a freshman
what the timetable is
i'm not exactly sure
if anything
november yes
we're thinking it's november but i don't
know for sure we have a commission that
ends in november that's why yes
representative platt yes just for
edification
federal energy regulatory commission is
ferc and so it's gas pipelines it's
electric transmission it's uh the
uh the
independent system operators uh and uh
indirectly generation by control of the
market but not directly generation so
it's got nothing to do with railroads
that service transportation board
but i have a question of representative
stavis
if if this is enabling legislation it's
not forcing
any any municipality to do anything they
could still say no how does that give a
railroad a leg up
uh i i would imagine i'll let
representative davis speak for herself
but i imagine that you're
probably
trying to navigate through a bunch of
lobbyists and
federal organizations
correct
and it and it doesn't really give them a
green light it's just yet another way of
making it easier
um and
you know i'm not pretending that that
this enabling legislation is going to
stop a railroad because that's just
never going to happen
but
in my view and in my experience
living near a freight line
they've got all the permission they need
and we don't need to give them more
i hope that answers your question
representative representative majipudi
uh thank you mr chair
just um you know knowing that to answers
uh one of your questions uh
representative powers is there's a
commission already established which is
working with def on addressing this
particular issue about the uh solid
waste
management in the state so we are this
bill is in the going in the right
direction so it won't
whether it is octopass or interim study
it will uh coincide with what they're
looking at what we got from
representative evil who chairs that
commission is that
you know you don't have to go through uh
dotting uh every eye and crossing every
t with this bill we are already getting
there in a few weeks we'll get the
recommendations so
and again like
our colleague my colleague
representative maggiore
you know
interim study or otp it's not going to
hurt we are moving in the right
direction okay the
the
question on the table is do you want to
otp
hb
that's the question
i see no objection why don't we call the
role
okay uh otp 1122. uh vice chairman p p
monty yes
clerk 4ts
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas yes
representative platt yes
representative melvin yes
representative here
representative power yes
representative majori
yes
representative uh representative gilman
representative stavis
upset of megapootie
yes
representative vann yes
representative klee yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan
18-0
so i have to report back to the sponsor
that his bill passed and i have to
apologize
so was it what was the vote 18-0
well will it make him feel happy
all right
so representative tripp are you going to
uh
write their committee report
or is it
is it uh representative power
um yes i will mr chair and also will
will this go on the consent calendar yes
it will unless there's an objection
okay
okay i believe the next one we have to
clean up
is the
revolving funds one
right
am i am i did i skip anything mr chair i
thought you uh when we discussed that
said you're going to recess it
the amendment's going to be brought back
and then we take it back up and if we
haven't seen the amendment you can't do
anything right right do we do we have an
amendment on 11 84
oh sorry
not yet
yeah we have three to take up
11 94 12 19 and 20 12 23.
yeah 1184 is uh close
okay so i'm
let's open the uh
the session on
house bill 1194 which is a relative
procedure for overriding a local tax cap
representative power
mis thank you mr chair i'd like to make
a motion on house bill
1194 i'd like to motion ought to pass
about to pass is there a second for that
representative
seconds it
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you mr chair the this bill is
an important bill
because we we've heard a lot about
unsustainable spending at the local
level with regard to um
municipalities as well as school
districts
so this
currently right now
tax caps are enabling legislation
and
a tax cap can be adopted by a super
majority
and the way that the law is right now is
that that tax cap can be over ridden
by a simple majority
and in my opinion there's really no
teeth in that type of a tax cap
so by changing the
vote
provision to override a tax cap
requiring a super majority
puts teeth into the tax cap
and it also
encourages
fiscal responsibility
in that
a super majority has to
vote and agree to override the tax cap
rather than a simple majority
and also i might point out that by
changing the
override
to three-fifths super majority it it
it mirrors the
vote threshold to adopt the tax cap
there additional discussion
about this bill 1194
seeing none
i'll ask their role the clerk to call
the role
okay 1194 ought to pass
uh advice chairman pm monty
yes
click folks yes representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative silas
yes
representative plett yes
representative melvin yes
representative
representative power yes
upset majority
no
uh representative
trailer no
representative gilman no
representatives davis no
representative vancouver
no
representative vann no
representative klee
no representative gallagher
no
representative ron no
chairman dolan
yes
otp passes 10 to 9.
okay this one i will not try to put that
on the consent calendar
do we have a
volunteer for um
look looking for a volunteer to write
the committee report the majority report
yes
i'll do that
mr chair i believe the minority report
will be coming from representative
gilman is that still true representative
gilman
thank you
before i close the hearing on
the
executive session is there any are there
any other further comments
representative maggiore and
representative mcdonald click off their
mics
okay
thank you
well it must been a good lunch because
we seem to be cooking right now
no lunch was cooked
don't
don't get too cocky right
[Music]
hb 1219
which is relative to parking
requirements
for religious
institution-affiliated housing
development projects
we are
do we have a uh
a motion
which is made to itl is there a second
would you like to speak to your motion
you don't have to
okay
representative gallagher do you have an
input
um
so
well i'd just like to
update the committee about
um where
or what the current status of
the bill is in terms of
what i've been talking with people about
um
so
the municipal association
um
mentioned that there was another bill
um house bill 1021
that passed out of judiciary and might
cover
the same cases i was carrying
i was carrying about here
with 12 19.
um so i emailed the sponsors of that
bill and the members of the judiciary
committee and
the person i heard back from joe
alexander at first seemed to say that
yes it would cover
the cases i don't care about here but
then on
um
further questioning uh he seemed to
change his mind and say no it
doesn't actually cover the cases so
since there's still
some
confusion about how this might interact
with other laws um
i think
well what i'd want to do with it would
be to
move this one to interim study too
so we can get some answers to how this
might
interact with other legislation and
clarify some of the other things that
people had questions about
okay we have a motion on the floor so
we'll have to wait to disposition that
one
first excuse me and then we can look at
additional motion
i checked and
we don't
have an uh an overriding
uh mo there is no overriding motion
like it like there is in the house
where where a
motion to table or
whatever is uh rises to the top and you
have to jump in so
um i was
educated
so we're going to take the motions in
order yes we have a
comment or
a quick comment yes thank you mr chair
just looking at at 10 21 which i've read
uh representative alexander it was good
that he responded but there are three
sponsors on that bill that we hadn't
heard back from yet a 1021 passed out
with a 14 to 7
vote i i just really i think that
there might be a good opportunity here
to see where we could
fold legislation together see how it
dovetails and works together rather than
having
different legislation trying to
accomplish the same goals
so i would uh i'll be voting against the
ipl
okay 10 21.
that's an older bill 12 19.
are you talking about 1219
judiciary has it sorry
okay
all right if we get any input does
anybody have any input back from
judiciary of of uh
what they're seeing on this bill
i believe that's what
i believe that's what uh representative
gallagher said that he heard back from
one of the four
sponsors
of 10 21. and they changed his mind
um to to be clear i don't think that
representative alexander was actually
one of the sponsors i thought he was
just a member of the judiciary committee
he is a he is a co-sponsor oh okay never
mind then
12 19.
okay 12 19 is ours so we have a motion
on the floor
to itl
yes miss representative um
i i have a lot of questions about this
bill in general
um
well i i think it's got good intent
which is why i would like to see it also
go to interim study my biggest concern
was something that got brought up i had
not thought about it was the tax
implications for housing of um
of religious
what i don't want to call religious
housing but housing on religious
property how that tax implication would
uh would work out which is why i think
an interim study rather than just trying
to kill this
might not be a bad uh are you concerned
that
this could take
non-taxable property and move it over to
being taxable
or or that non-taxable property
being used for the purpose of revenue
could then not be taxed and
versus if the same housing were put
somewhere else
um that i guess
but that's the question is would it or
wouldn't it and i i think to give it a
fair shot interim study might not be a
bad idea but just my thoughts thank you
further input
okay
you raising your hand
we have a motion on the floor in a
second
for
an itl on house bill 1219.
call the roll please
thank you mr chairman itlhb
1219.
uh representative pmit yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
yes sorry
representative melvin
yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majorie
no
representative trail evan no
representative gilman
no
representatives davis no
representative megapootie
no
representative van
representative clee
no representative gallagher
no
representative wrong no
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes
10 to 9.
you're up to do the committee report on
this one
and uh
well eric can you handle the report on
this sure excellent thank you okay
by the way these reports are
due to me
so use my email send them to me and then
what i do is i review them
and okay them and
for the month or the clerk
if
it doesn't come to me she'll she'll turn
turn around send it right
right to me or back to you
all right um
next is house bill 1223
which is relative to meeting attendance
requirements for elected members of the
budget committee and school board
yes representative wrong i move that we
itl house bill 1223.
you have a motion is and is it seconded
oh representative davis
okay is the discussion on the
on the motion to itl
yes representative wrong
yeah there's there's two things that
jump out on me on this one is the
definition of extenuating circumstances
um i would be more comfortable if there
were specific instances like illness
hospitalization death in the family
things like that
this leaves it up to the um
just the pleasure of the chair or the
other budget committee members
and the other thing
i i have trouble with with this bill it
says any member of an elected elected
budget committee who fails to attend two
or more scheduled and noticed meetings
or 25 of such meetings annually
shall be considered to have created a
vacancy in the elected position
i think it was representative tripp had
raised this issue before
i mean to miss two meetings i mean
we've had people on this committee that
have missed two meetings for
illness or hospitalization
but here there's no definition there's
no excused or accepted
i mean look how many members we've had
that have missed house sessions and
they're not kicked out of their
elected positions because of that so i
think this this goes
way overboard in ignoring the wishes of
the voters i think we need to really
protect the voters wish to have their
representation
and not have that removed from them
because of only having two absences
thank you we have an additional
discussion yes representative please
thank you mr chair i agree with
representative wrong and all that she
said
i couldn't help but think about this as
i read it when it talked about that it
would create an automatic vacancy
meaning that the person is removed
is that not kind of an end run to a
pseudo recall you're basically taking
them out of an elected position and one
of the nice things about new hampshire
is we don't do that
that's what kind of concerned me about
this
i know in the city of nashua we
the aldermen if you miss three in a
quarter um you're not entitled to your
stipend unless the entire body votes on
it to grant that exception and so on so
i i think that this is
literally removing someone from their
position that the body had elected and
um
that does concern me some i think it's a
slippery slope if we vote for this so
thank you thank you just a point of
information my and my town
we do have
a provision to remove a counselor
and it can be for whatever the council
wants it to be it can be for bad
attendance could be for
bad behavior but it has to be
a super majority of of uh four out of
five voting uh yes
that's just one one more town
yes representative tripp
i don't like i want to say that i agree
with representative klee
i think that if they're not doing the
job they shouldn't get paid of course
that has nothing to do with this bill so
thank you
representative power
thank you mr chair i'd like to um i have
concerns with this bill as written and
i'd like to point out that currently
under rsa 32 colon 15
roman numeral 6 that there is a
provision
with regard to but budget committee
membership that a member shall cease to
hold office immediately upon missing for
consecutive scheduled um
meetings without excuse so i don't see
that
this is addressed in this bill and might
be a
conflict representative
i'm sorry there was one more thing i
wanted to add i don't see an amendment
to it but in my notes
on
line 16 where it said 25 of such
meetings
um i put that it must be amended to 75
so
i think that was a typo and we don't
have an amendment to fix that so that
alone um
should kind of negate this
this bill is written
thank you
representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
say that my experiences most of the
communities have
their own policy and
it pretty much works out pretty good i
also suggest to you you have one heck of
a job getting rid of an elected official
on any board
and i think with that
you're probably right uh yes
representative platt mr chairman i'm i'm
doing my job as town budget committee in
manchester i still don't get paid
yes you have a question representative
yes
there seems to be uh some discrepancies
between this bill i
would suggest an interim study on this
if that
uh itl didn't pass
okay
no noted it doesn't take a higher
priority than what we're already looking
at yes representative
manjapudi
thank you mr chair i'm so glad you don't
forget my name
thank you mr chair just made it um
in my notes it you know uh
nhma said this could be addressed by
bylaw at the local level so if they have
a bylaw you know you miss so many
meetings and again i think the notes uh
also indicate for me that this is
establishing an alternative to a
democratic process which is already in
play
place where the voters elect these uh
members and to be removed by the
voters would be the
right way and
or having a bylaw and which is already
in place so this seems
[Music]
establishing a
bypass
to that so at least in my mind
yes represent my jury thank you mr chair
and i would argue i think i'm piling on
that statute 91a already says that you
may allow these you may allow somebody
to participate
uh if they're absent for whatever reason
and the budget committee decides that
they are not going to allow that person
to participate so be it they
so
only if the budget committee finds
extenuating circumstances and allows the
participation is already covered in 92
91a it seems to me to be duplicative and
only is
looking for
somebody to say to file a court order to
say
uh they have a disagreement i think this
bill is looking for a prop looking for a
problem
thank you
what's going to be your recommendation
of that of that
bill just curious
i'm sorry are you going to
um
want to itl or otp
or oh i'm sorry i want an ipl or intern
yeah
there's an itl uh motion on the table
right now yes
there's a there's another motion for it
for
interim study but
it will have to be
ruled upon after we deal with the itl
if we get that far
any further discussion
on the itl motion
seeing none uh
i'd like to collect to take a roll
please
thank you mr chairman
itl on hb 1223. by 7pm monty no
clerk votes
no
representative chip
yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
no
representative plant no
representative melvin
representative
representative power
yes what was the majority yes
representative of 2011
yes
representative gilman yes representative
davis yes
representing yes
representative vann yes
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
representative rung
yes
chairman dolan no
itl passes 12 to seven
so representative maturi
that motion for interim study is not in
order
you have an idea who's going to do the
majority report representative wrong are
you still good for that
excellent
and from our side who's gonna do this
we have to notice it all right
we have a volunteer to write the uh
majority report
no it's a minority
you've got it i just need a minority
yeah we get the minority no we don't no
majority no oh you do
that's right we need a minority
you got to give us the minority i mean
the majority once in a while
all right come on
candidates for uh the minority report
i know you're not used to being in the
minority but
i voted with a majority so i i don't
think it would be fair to steal the
minorities thunder maybe representative
wrong would want your assistance
hey joe
can you uh write the minority report on
this one on on
12 23.
okay
it was itl 12 12-7 i thought it was in a
majority
i know
i believe so yeah you are in the
majority
oh that's right you were in the majority
i would just like to
make everyone
aware that i enjoyed the railroad
stories
let's keep this on track
okay
okay we're gonna adjourn we have uh
mr chair
no we apparently we can't
we're still waiting for the amendment so
mr chair yes
uh there's another possibility
uh as i was uh discussing with
representative power and representative
clee
about the the two changes and also
representative tripp
about the two um
scribing changes
the person from new hampshire municipal
association
said that it's their position that they
think the whole bill may in fact be
redundant
and say the same thing
and so
if we wanted to ask their opinion at
this point
we might be more inclined to simply itl
the bill
because i don't have the amendment yet
and they promised it to me and
i don't see it coming
any other input on that
can we put you on the spot and ask your
opinion
no no we can't we're in executive
session we can't do that
oh you can ask
[Music]
do you support
the revolving fund this one
okay
good afternoon committee members
my name is katherine heck i'm with the
new hampshire municipal association and
i'm happy to take your questions
well what we're
debating is
uh hb 1184 which is
the which would authorize
towns and municipalities
to establish a revolving fund
so if you read
page 2
line six to amend rsa 44
cities are already allowed to
establish and use revolving funds for
all the purposes created because the rsa
allows them to do anything a town can do
so it's redundant that language and in
village districts which would start
on page three line three
rsa 52 already permits a village
district for the purpose for which it
was created to do anything a town can do
but only within its purpose so they also
if can create a revolving fund for that
purpose
counties we don't take a position on so
this legislation had been targeted and
geared toward counties
so that's um our position is that this
language is completely redundant and
most likely unnecessary as cities and
village districts can already establish
revolving funds thank you catherine uh
given that
additional information what do you all
think
i'd like to
move that we itl
for further work so there's no no motion
on the floor at the moment right
yes representative wrong
yeah i realize miss heck that cities
towns and village districts already have
the power to set up a revolving fund but
what about counties
i think when when representative lang
introduced this bill
he he meant that he wanted to extend the
capabilities of having revolving funds
to counties in addition to cities and
village districts
i recall his testimony and when he
introduced the bill and that is correct
he wanted to extend
that ability to counties which is
currently not
in the rsa that a county can create a
revolving or establish a revolving fund
but we have no position on the county
portion all right representative uh van
was that one of the corrections
well
i talked to ols about it and they said
that they
uh
since the primary sponsor was there i
was only there to fix the scribing
errors and they said that by the end of
the day today they could not
fix all that they acknowledged that
the cities and towns the cities towns
and village districts could already do
this
they agreed that that language was all
quite redundant
my
sense at this point is that we'd be
better off itlling this bill
and making a better stab at it next time
because it's going to create confusion i
think
by saying the same thing in several
different places okay any additional
input
yes representative power
thank you mr chair i was just curious to
to understand
do counties
engage in activities
listed in line seven through g
i i
i i meant seven through
um
18.
my understanding is that currently they
do not engage in all of those activities
from my understanding that is my opinion
any further i missed it
i think the only thing that because the
counties are only responsible for ambula
i mean
elderly care
nursing home and correctional
so only the ambulance service
or something like that in that
safety providing public safety services
those are the only two categories that
might affect the county at the county
level
we have a lot of sheriffs out there too
yeah so that's what public safety and uh
senior care
not the energy not
education so
okay yes representative wrong yes thank
you mr chair
um
i know we all want to get out of here
but
i i do think that
it is fair to extend revolving funds to
counties and our problem may be solved
if we just strike out section two
to the end of the bill and just keep
section one what refers to county
um
my uh
you know i i look at county activities
and and revolving from to me would be
very appropriate for let's say county
fairs you know where they are taking in
revenue it is just defined for that
purpose it would make the administration
and the organization and management of
county fairs more efficient if they had
access to that fund outside of their
normal budget
um so
i don't know i i'm going to if there is
a motion to itl i'm going to oppose it
and
hope that we can get an amendment that
only maintains section one
and i would be happy if
to go and get that amendment
okay so um
i hear what you're saying i think what
we might do is
scrub that uh
that bill and see if we can
do without it like you're suggesting but
i haven't had a chance to uh
to scrub it yet what um
would the committee
indulge me five minutes and then we can
dispose of this bill
uh i think i can go through it in five
minutes
good all right uh we're gonna take a
recess for five minutes
she said that if we just struck out two
lines it wouldn't it wouldn't
these
instructs
i can count keeping the county just the
county health
yes
um
okay
and if you look at the last provision
for the counties that the legislative
body can adopt and read just this one
line
any purpose
otherwise
that language
but the problem i have is right now this
new language which is in the
in
in the bill
talks about county
and if we
unless we strike this
well that's what i'm saying but if it
was
anything for which
[Music]
i was going to ask
van but do you know
the language
okay
i think i have to agree with that
the whole thing was changed
all right let's get back to work
okay we've been having discussions about
how we uh clean this up uh 11 hb 1184
and it was a suggestion was made that we
could
delete uh
a few paragraphs and we would almost be
there
uh i've had that conference with several
of you
and
what we've decided
you know i'll ask you all to confirm
this what we've decided is
there's just there's just too much
messed up in this bill right now and
there's no
there are no
co co-authors co-sponsors here to to
help us out so
i i'm going to suggest that we itl
1184 because of that
yes representative loseless
mr chairman it seems
that
there is a need for
counties
to have a revolving fund
there is that need i and i can see where
like police details
why wouldn't we want to have a revolving
fund for county sheriffs to
serve on police details
so
knowing that there is a need rather than
itlling it
wouldn't it be more appropriate to do an
interim study
that's possible
that is a legal motion
yes representative mr chair and
practical matter in the second year of
return and i tl and i associate the same
thing
interim study kills it the author could
come back with a new bill just on
counties
yeah that's what i'm thinking it's a new
bill just for counties yes
representative ron
is it possible if if the itl i don't
think there's a motion on the floor but
if there was an itl motion on the floor
and it failed
um
could
could i come back next at our next
meeting with an amendment that just
addresses county we have to do it today
the only
uh
little little amount of room i have with
that is if it's the last bill of the day
we don't finish
oh okay so we can't bring this up in our
next exact session
okay if if we were talking about 12 23
the answer might be different
oh okay
you follow what i'm saying
this is this is
it may not make sense but
we all have uh rules we have to follow
and that that's her uh mrs smith
well um a question mr chair
didn't we do that on didn't we do a bill
today that we were supposed to do
yesterday
10.70
oh was that it yeah we carried over a
bill from yesterday that we didn't take
action on
um
we reconsidered that
it was passed and it was reconsidered
and the world changed there was no i
think there was another bill also that
yeah it was it was the last bill of the
day oh the last bill from yesterday we
did today so that's that's our only uh
oh okay
in that situation okay
i know it seems weird but that's the way
it is yes
i know this is gonna sound convoluted
but could we not vote on it and then
reconsider it tomorrow as you did with
1070.
if we won't be here oh the next the 28th
may ask a question mr chair
yes
thank you mr chair
if we do that
we haven't changed the bill
into what you might want it to be to
include the counties
or
just counties where this is redundant
that it already has
cities
villages
towns
so if the goal is to include the
counties
how do we get there
yeah
if you either interim study or itl today
i don't know how you can get over less
to act on an amendment
uh and so it'd be possible to bring it
back so the only thing you could do
today is ought to pass
uh
and then reconsider that but you could i
don't know i i'm just procedurally how
you get a wellness to act if it's not
if it's got any vote on it mr chairman
what happens if we take no action
on this bill
take no action
does that mean
that it's just we still own the bill and
we can take it up at any time what
happens is i get in trouble
move move to recess
yes
the
report said to me before friday
so that shoots that off
the actions you want to then want to
make it sooner
well i'm i am tiptoeing around
around the edge of the rule so please
don't push me over the edge
one suggestion i just heard that
i think i can swallow is
is to otp
and then reconsider that
but even then if you otp how do you go
to ols for any kind of amendment when
you passed a bill yeah we think we'd
have to do we'd have to have an
understanding and i think representative
wrong has some ideas that of what
strikeouts
have to be made
yeah it really it's just keeping section
one
because the section two which revolves
cities in section three which involves
village districts are redundant we don't
need those we just need section one
we just would be adding counties
um
you know enabling them to have because
it's enabling it's a county may by vote
of the county delegation establish a
revolving fund
uh yeah i think we can just ask ols to
do that they don't check to see what
we've done with the bill
you can just go in there and ask
anything anybody else have an input on
this yes
mr chair should we should we um
contact um the honorable uh clerk uh
paul smith to see if it's something that
or should we just i see that uh
representative majority came running in
here with his hand up so he may have
some news for us well i just wanted to
say that that um heather needs to post
the meeting pope needs to post the
hearing on this i'm not sure that we can
reconsider a vote on a bill without
posting that bill so i don't i have no
idea how that happens and she's going to
be looking for us to post something the
calendar limitation is today by thursday
all postings have to be input to the to
the clerk
and that's close of business thursday
yeah yeah i i hate to put a
a little crimp in this but the la the
next two
calendars
um for this have already been revised
and i know you can't revise
uh you can't revise a revised agenda
so i don't we can't purposely do it but
if
we voted on it and then just like today
suddenly something became reconsidered
that could be done as long as it wasn't
handed into the clerk beforehand
that's all i'm saying
any other input
yes representative power
thank you mr chair um
i would advocate to itl the bill and
then to
have the sponsors rework this and bring
it back
and then redo the whole process i i feel
very uncomfortable
trying to do something so quickly
piecemeal
we've gone through a couple of different
um
i guess iterations or suggestions of
what an amendment would look like and
this is not careful work
so i recommend itlling it
do you uh
have the uh connections right now to
work with the sponsors
no no i don't
know but we're going to bring it back
next year next year oh right we can kill
it yeah i think we're looking for for uh
ways not to kill it if if uh if we otp'd
it i'm gonna move towards whether if we
if we did it
yes i think that we can
have the sponsors
come back to us during another executive
session and
and ask us to
to uh change it but i think that we're
gonna have to wait till the next session
to do that
i just have a question
mr chairman um
there was a bill that i was a prime
sponsor of that went to resources
and they weren't ready to execute so it
went on their next agenda
is that something we can do since we
haven't taken any action on this can we
just well our agenda for next week has
been posted oh that okay
okay
representative
is
is the opportunity for
is the opportunity for a floor amendment
at the next session
is that an opportunity
[Music]
so if we
either one
i i don't like the connotation of
itl
so if it's legislation that we can
possibly live with
if we otp it and then on the floor
as part of the session have a bipartisan
floor amendment
that would
well the
only
caveat is that there's going to be a lot
more than 19 people voting on it on the
floor so
you have to go round up all
your minions and they have to go up and
round up all their minions and it won't
be 11
to 10 anymore
i mean if if
the house votes it down they vote it
down
it's done
but at least i i feel that there is a
benefit to this legislation
i i think the clerk was next but i'm
sorry if the clerk is willing to let me
speak
thank you mr chair thank you mr clerk
um this bill this bill now belongs to
our committee
and in my view it's our responsibility
to move it one way or the other
uh
to if if we think that it's worth
preserving somebody should move otp if
we don't somebody should move itl but i
think that going back and forth
with multiple
amendments and nobody's really clear on
what the amendments are it's not living
up to our responsibility as a committee
and that's just my view so thank you for
listening
thank you for that input
representative mcdonald and
representative tripp
i'd like to make a motion to itl
1184.
second second we all second i didn't
hear what you said 12 seconds
excuse me a motion to itl 1184.
been made in second
discussion representative tripp
i think this is probably the wisest
thing to do because
if we was to otp it we would be relying
on something happening at ols which
apparently isn't uh
something that uh
it works all the time so i think i
telling it uh
makes
makes it uh
i think the bot the bill is flawed right
now
and i think to otp it would be a mistake
so if we itl it uh and we get a
an amendment that's good if we itl it
and we don't get an amendment that's
good too
you know so
amendment is that what you mean either
or
you know but uh but i don't think that
we should move a flawed bill forward
okay
okay i don't want to stack the deck but
i think that
we'd have to do this if we're going to
itl it and wait for a new amendment to
come through we have to have
some little uh
secret handshake that we're going to
support
an on the floor amendment
yes representative
i agree with representative tripp i
think we should dispose of this as
representative stavis has said
my preference is itl um and then if the
sponsor at that time decides that they
want to come forward with the amendment
and work the floor to get it overturned
to not to pass we should leave it to
them but right now it is in our hand and
we should put through
the best bill we can
at this point we can't change it so i
think we should i tell you
we have a uh
a motion to itl
and we have it uh
also seconded yes i was just gonna
move we're getting close
mr chair i'll i'll just uh give everyone
a heads up that i i will i'm going to
vote against the itl um
and i'll be prepared to do my very first
floor amendment and i look forward to
your support thank you
okay
any other any further inputs
seeing none
let's call the role on an ito
kitl1184 uh
vice chairman pmrt
yes
clerk votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie yes
representative los alas
no
uh representative pled yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majori
yes
representative gilman yes
representative stavis yes
representative meg deputy yes
representative vann
yes
representative clee yes
representative gallagher
yes
representative rung
no
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 17 to 2.
hey without objection i'll put this on
the consent oh i can't because it has a
fiscal note right
or you object i object
and i'm going to object to it it only
takes one to
to stop it
okay as a reminder we have two sessions
next week tuesday and wednesday again
you too joe enjoy the rest of the day
representative guthrie can i ask you to
stay for a second
tuesday the 22nd and wednesday the 23rd
yeah
okay so i'll see you next week
next tuesday
next monday
mr chair thank you for the opportunity
to be part of this today
well thanks thanks for being here we
appreciate your help
joe how do i do that joe
joe country
thanks
you